this is Joo podcast number 418 with
Carrie hton and me Joo willink good
evening Carrie good
evening I was I was raised in the SEAL
Teams and and I know that at least I say
that right and I know that I wasn't
actually raised in the SEAL
Teams but when I consider who I am today
and what my values are and what my
principles are what my driving force in
my personality are the vast majority of
them came not from where I grew up as a
kid but came from the SEAL Teams or more
specifically
from my fellow frog men in the SEAL
Teams and there's all kinds of different
guys in the teams there's the guy that
worked hard they the guy that makes
things happen there's that tough guy
there's the chief that looked out for
the
boys the officer that kept us out of
trouble the guy that was awesome in the
field guy that knew how to fight the guy
that could fix any
engine the guy that asked really good
questions the serious guy the
professional guy there's just all these
different individuals in the SEAL
Teams and and they say that there's that
saying I guess I don't know want to say
they say but there's a saying that you
are the average of the your five closest
friends well in the teams you got a lot
of friends and all those guys leave a
mark on you especially when you're young
right I I've had many conversations with
people about the impression that gets
imprinted on you in your first platoon
and a lot of times you think that that's
the way the world should be is the way
it was in your first platoon but it does
continue to develop and you continue to
change and you continue to grow but you
really get you really get formulated a
lot in your early days in the SEAL Teams
and everyone leaves a mark on you that
you work
with and of course there's some guys
that you don't like there's some guys
that you
reject that you look at them and think
I'm not going to be like that these are
the Slackers or the lazy guys or the
incompetent guys but the good
guys you try and do what they do and
that's what I did in my career I tried
to
reject the bad examples and I tried to
emulate the good ones and there were a
lot of good ones along the way
that made a mark and one of them was a
guy named Mark coach
coacho who spent 30 30 years in Naval
special Warfare actually more than 30
years in Naval special Warfare he served
in all kinds of different seal commands
including the jck command he rose up
through the ranks eventually retiring as
a warrant officer and even after that he
continued to work in the
teams and he had an
attitude that I always remembered and I
always admired when I was a new guy
a positive attitude that was just always
ready to go and it's an honor to have
him here with us here tonight to share
his experiences and Lessons Learned Mark
coach thanks for joining us yeah man um
wow that's an intro I was I was getting
worried there when he said there those
guys you don't like it's like oh [__] is
that me it was a
[Music]
setup and it's a dishonor to have one of
those guys here tonight to tell you guys
not to act yeah yeah there'll be plenty
of that I'm sure plenty of not acting
good but yeah whatever uh yeah no I I
always remember we'll get to it but uh I
always you know you definitely left a
mark on me when I was a young new guy
because you were not a new guy at the
time I think you were four five platoon
deep and four and five platoon deep guys
can act a bunch of different ways and
the way that you acted the way you I was
I think I might have turned 21 yeah cuz
we were on diplom so I was 21 but I mean
I was like young and dumb
and full of
motivation and and you were just a great
cool guy that set a great example for me
and some of the other new guys that were
out there at the time but we'll get all
that um let's start at the beginning so
so where'd you grow
up um California uh did all my um
Elementary School in little place called
Pismo Beach Pismo yeah Pismo Beach yeah
we were dirt poor uhhuh me and my mom
dad and four brothers and uh damn Four
Brothers what number are you I'm two
number two yeah what did your dad do for
a living um well at the time um he was
going to school so was my mom so they
were both getting their teaching
credentials and stuff through calp and
oh so you were up there they were up
there slow yeah yeah but we lived in
Pismo Beach and you know I don't know if
you're familiar with it but you know
there's a a restaurant called M mclin
talkx okay it's up off a matty Road
right you know looking over the ocean
million million multi-million dollar
View uhhuh yeah we lived in a little
green Farmhouse bu a bunk house um I
think the rent was like 90 bucks a month
May mean it was we were just yeah yeah
and so were you kind of like a free
range child that was just running around
doing whatever while your kid parents
are going to school yeah big time that
was that was the thing you know we went
to school we got dropped off either by
the bus or you know whatever you know
landed us back at home and we were just
there you know running around the hills
and chasing cows and you know
all that we didn't have any money so
it's like you didn't get to like learn
how to ride a horse or anything like
that but yeah you run around chase the
horses and you know you get chased by
the bull and just just oh God it's
amazing I'm still amazed that all my
brothers grew up with all our fingers
and sight in both eyes cuz uh we did
some really stupid stuff and how long
did you live there for um well um
kindergarten through sixth grade so
about seven years so when you're in
sixth grade what are you 10 years old
old um maybe actually 11 12 you had some
legit time there yeah oh yeah and I mean
right there at the beach you of course
it was almost three miles to get to the
beach so we didn't have any money or
Transportation so I grew up watching the
ocean never learned to Surf no
bummer swam around in a bunch and you
know we'd ride our bikes down there when
we were a little bit older and we'd swim
around in our Levis or well they weren't
even Levis they were tough skins you
know remember those searious tough skins
ser and we would swim just wearing our
pants and when then we get back on the
bike and ride home and you dry off on
the way home wonder why you're chafed
you
know so then what where'd you move to
next and why why well the folks uh
graduated and got a job uh in San Jose
California Wait so your parents they're
they're going to school but they already
had four kids is that what I'm hearing
yeah yeah so was this bad planning or my
dad made a course correction um he found
himself in this really horrible job that
was driving him crazy it's like screw
this what was it um he was working for
the California Youth Authority okay so
he was dealing with just you know
troubled kids and and it wasn't the kids
that were the issue it was the
administration the bureaucracy yeah and
he was like I can't do this I hate you
know he'd come home and he' just be just
completely pissed off and I was too
young to remember all that but he was
like you know what screw it we're going
to go back get our you know teaching
credentials and uh you know they took
turns you know you know working on OD
job and the other one would go to school
back and forth and so they both got
their teaching credentials there at slow
yeah yeah um my dad got a job at the
actually at the high school I went to
okay and uh my mom worked at a
continuation High School in Gilroy okay
um but yeah so we we rolled up there and
oh when was it to like 79 78 something
like that I don't remember um but Junior
High in high school was all in sound
Jose okay east side of San Jose which
you know it makes like the or back then
I don't know what it is now but it was
always made in the top 10 for murders in
uh in the United States you know a lot
of gang activity and crap like that and
you know most of the guys looked um that
you know lived around us or either dead
or in jail MH you know um but you know
kind of stayed kept my nose clean out of
that as much as I could what were you
doing in in like high school were you
playing sports well my folks got us into
uh Taekwondo okay so that's what I was
doing and it they also taught um our nie
which I really liked the stick fighting
knife fighting type deal it teaches you
angles it keeps you on your feet you
know it was a it was it's it's
streetable stuff yeah so I kind of and
then later later on I I I trained in
when we were in the Philippines with the
Filipinos and then in San Diego we found
a place called sep of brothers and my
brother and I trained there for a bit
what are you doing at school are you
getting good grades are you like a
knucklehead are you just passing and
getting it done I was just passing but I
I really like photography so I was the
you know one of the photographers for
the school newspaper and yearbook and
all that crap and you know I thought
okay I could probably you know do this
for a living you know and that you know
it was just it was pretty easy for me
and if I likeed the subject I did good
in it if I didn't then uh yeah so I
think I graduated a mean 2.3 you know
GPA there you go are had you heard about
the military like what was making you
think about the military did you had you
heard of the SEAL Teams yet no no in in
1984 there was no you know unless you
knew a seal you didn't know anything um
but you know both my folks being uh you
know High School teachers they were big
on you know hey you're going to college
you're going to college but we can't pay
it so you have to find your own money
and uh the Navy had this cool deal where
they gave you money for college and hey
hey photographers made you know I can go
be a Navy photographer for a while so
that's what I did and um yeah so I I
graduated um on the 14th of June
1984 and on the fifth morning of the
15th I was on my way to Orlando Florida
rolling right in did you know what to
expect cuz you'd never been around the
military oh I had no idea dude I I
walked in there was like complete
culture shock it was exactly what they
wanted to do to you like you all of a
sudden you just walking out oh yeah here
shut up and sit you know stand there all
that stuff yeah it was it was um it was
eye opening but it was also really
stupid you know and that's honestly that
that's how I got interested in the SEAL
Teams because it you know boot camp I
was expecting to be a challenge it was
going to be this oh yeah you know di is
gonna come in and yell at me and throw
[__] around no now the lights came on
okay guys get up I'm like what the hell
and it was just about folding your
clothes and you know just stupid stuff
like that I was like dude this is dumb
what else you got and one of the guys
was like well we got this UDT SEAL
program what's that well you get to jump
at airplanes shoot guns and blow stuff
up it's like dude sign me up did you
find out about that in boot camp or was
it after boot camp I found out about
that in boot camp okay but
I so I um my mom I was 17 so my mom had
to sign for me to get into the military
and she wouldn't sign active duty order
so I had to go reservist at first so I
spent your mom was smart it's actually a
smart move you're a 17-year-old kid
you're like yo you don't know what
you're getting into how about we do this
Reserve thing yeah that's actually not a
bad move mom well yeah and it it turned
out probably pretty good because um when
my son-in-law was going through training
he said that half of his class half of
the 200 guys were 18 years old and none
of them made it not a single one cuz
there's just not that maturity level yet
um but Gardner you know Jason Gardner he
was like of course you know Jason um but
yeah we we heard some stat that if
you're under 20 years old it's a 5%
chance of making it through so yeah it's
like you got to have that little
something I guess extra a little bit of
moto me and Jason Gardner we were both
like 18 or 19 so get some Jason was
actually I think he was actually he
might have been 17 turning 18 wow he's
pretty freaking young uh so did you like
do so did you go to photographer's mate
school or something yep I did boot camp
and photo mate School 6 months in
Florida and then uh came back and I was
a drilling reservist for about a year uh
the whole time what do you do as a
Drilling reservice in the Navy well I
drive up to uh Alam from San Jose take
some pictures one weekend a month and
work in the photo lab there and yeah
take pictures of stuff and develop film
and and just do stupid Navy stuff and uh
yeah I was like okay how do I get active
duty orders and no one had ever gone
active duty from that place so they had
no idea turned out all I had to do was
just not show up and they would
activated me but I didn't want to be
that you know a black mark like oh no
now I got to go to a ship I can't go you
know be a seal and um it took God it
took a long time damn near a year of
just drilling back and forth hitting the
the my recruiter up and and this is
trying to get to go active duty go
trying to go active duty and get buds so
I drove um you know I did the screening
test so I drove down to San Diego took
the test and ran back and then and went
home in like two days um were you doing
anything to like train
yeah well funny you should ask U yeah it
was like okay uh what's the I was
training for the PST cuz that's all I
knew so underwater recovery stroke um
you know use the the school pool cuz my
dad was still you know you know a uh an
instructor there so I could um you know
just practice the breast stroke and I
say okay you got to run so I ran some
got to do some calisthenics that's never
been hard I could do pull-ups and
push-ups and stuff like that but
yeah um the first time I ran with uh
with boondockers on was was that day so
you had uh back then it was a mile in 7
and a half minutes and I made that
sucker in
so yeah and it was good enough to get me
uh through the door but okay I'm G to
have to up that number you know make
that better MH um and then yeah I drove
back and kept training and you know they
finally figured out you know that uh you
know how to do it and uh activated me
and I rolled back in and uh I
got got to San Diego too early like
three months too early um from my from
the class so you're on active duty you
get activated and they send you down
here sent me down here they had to go
through two weeks of navet training you
know just you know it was for all the
all the guys who you know tried to get
away with going their Reserve meetings
and stuff so yeah that was a little anti
motivational um but yeah so they they
stowed me over at uh EOD mobile unit 3
and so we just did the slave labor for
those guys for like three months um and
then you know classed up with uh 141 and
how'd that go uh well it was buds man I
mean
uh yeah um had its its highs and its
lows you know and people always ask me
what was buds like well it's the the
worst time in your life that you'll ever
miss you know yeah cuz and it's so pure
you know it's like just
survive this next Evolution you know and
that's how you make it through hell week
you think okay you set these little
goals like uh uh there was one guy Fred
Swanson um he was a chief and I was like
really really really cold you know right
at breakout I was like holy crap I don't
know if I can do this were you like 145
lb I was 143 lb I graduated high school
there that was what was buds I came back
from my first deployment zero body fat
oh dude I was so negative yeah when it
came to drown proofing and you know
they're talking oh yeah no we're going
to tie your hands you know okay but no
one's negative you just got to relax you
know I'm like okay and I believed it I
bought into it you know like okay you
jumped in the pool okay John just relax
and you'll float and so I could close my
eyes and I'm relaxing relaxing and then
I feel my feet hit with some Authority
on the bottom of the pool I'm like I
look up like well am I have to figure
something else out so while everybody
else was floating I was kicking the
whole time you know because otherwise
yeah do they really say no one's
negative yeah that that's what the uh
the rumor was trying to tell everybody
that's what the instructor was say oh
yeah no one's negative I had a kid in my
class he was a he was from Africa he was
like he was American citizen but he
lived his first whatever 10 years in
life in Africa super nice guy like a
physical stud bro they th they pushed
him in the pool for drown proofing he
just went literally straight to the
bottom with a lot of authority and he
didn't come up like whatever position he
landed in like they had to go get him
and he never he never made it like he
was just too he had no body fat
whatsoever and if you don't have any
body fat whatsoever you are going to be
negative and you're going down yeah but
I mean I mean there's there's ways to
figure it out I was comfortable in the
water cuz I grew up around the water so
I was like okay I can I I knew I could
figure it out but I mean you got to you
know swim the length of the pool you
know the long way and back you know with
your hands and feet tied well that was
after you know kicking for you know
those those 20 breaths or what the hell
the the the requirement was so it was a
lot more energy that I had to put out
but U yeah and so you say you were
saying you were freezing and some Chief
was going to hook you up oh yeah so um
Fred Swanson was the uh the the seal
motivator okay that that was there for
that class and if any other instructor
had heard me just you can whine a little
bit it was would have been a full court
press to smash me right but he just kind
of n what here's what you want to do
never quit during an evolution always
tell yourself you feel like you're going
to quit quit after the evolution I'm
like
okay okay so yeah you I mean you're
freezing cold and then what's the next
thing you do oh a race we warm you up
again you know okay and I was like all
right and then that was it man you
whatever it was it could suck it would
just be the worst possible thing I'm
like I'm going to make it through this
and then I'll see what's you know if see
what I want to do you know and you want
to see the sunrise you know it's like
okay there's my goal see the sunrise or
make it to the next meal I mean getting
you know four meals a day and still just
losing weight yeah it was but yeah you
um so I I've U been in one hell week and
I've seen one hell week you know I work
you only worked one hell week only
worked one CU I was always on the island
when I was uh you know um an instructor
um but uh watching a hell week right
there as things are going down you're
like oh my God we are killing these kids
somebody is going to die here you know
but yeah there there's a method to the
madness yeah um and um they're still
doing it right you know you're never
going to get everybody that needs to go
I
mean it doesn't take much training to
motivate somebody to just survive
through whatever that next evolution is
yeah there there is like a there is you
know people that are going to make it
through hell week just talking hell week
definitely there's people that are like
oh they made it through because they
were super motivated and they want to
make it happen and they bring together
the team and there's a bunch of guys
that are like part of that team that's
getting brought together there's some
dudes that are literally just trying to
make it through for themselves and it is
a group of people it's not huge but and
I actually had this conversation I was
working with the Admiral when I was the
Admiral's age and he said something
along the lines he's like you know we
went down secure to hell week you know I
didn't he went down secure to hell week
I stood there like a freaking jackass
you know giving him whatever he needed
and but you know when we're coming back
he's like you know the one thing is he's
like you know one thing Joo it proves
these guys are tough and I was like Hey
sir sometimes I go sometimes it proves
they figure out a way to sneak through
the system and he was kind of like
that's a good point cuz you know it's
true there's some guys that figure out a
way they do just they in the right spot
they get in the right spot on the boat
they get in the right spot on the log
they get in the right spot they they're
they're good enough to they they sit out
that one Evolution they can tell when
something count they just esape and
there's definitely a group of guys like
that and it's easier to do now because
uh the the there's information out there
well yeah I was going to say that too
with look there was very limited
information when I went and I went in 19
90 so 1991 I was in buds so the amount
of information for you was just like
there was nothing now the these guys
they have like the class schedule they
watch the movie they seen the videos the
documentary so they they kind of know
what's coming but I also the but I also
know that the instructors now they they
have counter measures for all this [__]
they have fake schedules like it's
they're going to get you they're going
to get you hell week's not going to be
easy buds is not going to be easy anyone
that thinks it's going to be easy is
going to have a real hard time like
they're going to figure out how to make
it hard you know summer hell week winter
hell week they're going to figure out
way you're going to get cold you're
going to be cold it's just how how long
do you stay in the water you know um
yeah I mean buds for for us it was
basically the same thing um was just you
know first phase was a kicking the nuts
and second phase was an underwater
kicking the nuts and then third phase
was here's your gun and your bomb Oh and
you're kicking the
nuts um when we figured out as I became
an instructor um we wanted to make it so
that we're actually training them and uh
that was that was the big Focus then at
me being an instructor what year was
that um geez uh I got to to buds um as
the third phase training officer in
December
of7 okay so we were well into the war
and everything and we need you guys to
be better yeah yeah guys yeah and and I
looking at myself um I was still
fighting a lot of training scars cuz I
didn't learn how to shoot in buds you
know I I did okay I I you know got my my
two e ribbons but uh you know I had no
idea um and it wasn't until I I you know
got to that Socom unit that you're
talking jck is that what we're calling
okay um that's that's when I learned to
shoot yeah and I was fighting all of
these really bad habits so I figured
well if we could get these guys early on
no bad habits and drill them up you know
I'd tell them hey look I'm not trying to
make you as good a shot as me I'm trying
to make you way better cuz I'm still
fighting these training scars from years
ago yeah cuz the what I was talking
about the opening there the first
impressions that you get in the teams
like your first platoon it's hard to
shake some of that stuff you're like you
get you get a mold on your brain and
you're like all right it's just in there
and that's what you think is right and
you got to that's
you know you talk about the training
habits of like your shooting position
and all that stuff but also just your
mindset and the way you think if you're
not careful you can think that what you
learned in your first platoon or your
second platoon you can think that that's
the right way and every and it's like
man it's first of all there's many many
many many different ways to skin a cat
and anytime someone says no this is the
right way I'm I always get a little bit
suspect like man there's a lot of right
ways do this yeah a lot of right ways
yeah when they say it's the only way
it's like no no no okay I'm I'm
immediately skeptical of your uh your
intentions you know did you have any
challenges in buds was anything like
super hard for did you fail did you get
rolled back uh no I didn't get rolled
back um I made pretty much everything
every time the one the one thing was the
the tread um my legs cramped up and I
sank and I mean cuz I was like I said
you know had no fat on me and I got cold
and the cold was was just it would go
right through me and you know you know
when that happens and you're like now
you're required to put out this extra
effort and you know when both your your
thighs just ball up on you it's kind of
hard to To Tread with your hands out of
the water and the tanks on your back um
so that I came back the next day and did
it but right then it was like holy you
ate a bunch of bananas you know get that
potass right there you that was the
extent of our nutritional information at
the time add cramps eat bananas all
good they weren't even really telling us
to drink water yet like I think drinking
water as like a performance or health
thing was kind of coming in around when
I was in buds like some of the
instructors would be like oh you should
drink some water like it wasn't hey man
you really need to drink water you know
you're going to get dehydrated it's not
good for you it was it wasn't really a
thing yet yeah I I can't remember ever
taking a drink of water in buds you know
in h we we had these like nurses that
were following us around trying to
figure out what the X Factor was they
did for three classes you know they they
measured our you know they watched what
you ate when you went through the line
and you estimated how much you were
drinking and all this and um yeah
doesn't mean anything yeah what they
they found out you know the the results
of that was um the guy who quits and the
guy who makes it through are exactly the
same you know the differences you know
neck up you know it's whatever your
brain can can make your body do yeah um
and they just confir Med it for us we
knew that already yeah and you were all
good in the water cuz you grew up
swimming up so like pool comp and all
that stuff no Factor yeah no no it was
fact that um when they did the I think I
was the third guy to go so they were
still the instructors motivated you know
as they they goes along you okay we're
just going to do this guy no no this was
like yeah the guy who did me was uh was
very
motivated um but I remember uh you know
using the breathing technique like going
okay calm myself all right here we go
and as soon as I got in the water they
were playing the the uh the themes song
from from Jaws you know D it on the
underwater the underwater speaker yeah
so immediately that put me at ease I was
like okay this is funny right and
they're like okay I just swim along that
line and then they'd come and they'd hit
you and they'd do this and it just got
progressively worse and I just it was it
you went through the process and it was
like no problem no Factor no no and you
know being comfortable underwater I
liked being underwater I could hold my
breath for a long time so it wasn't you
know that big a deal and I was just like
hey you do what they tell you I failed
pool comp the first time and the
instructor was he was also highly
motivated and you know him he's a worn
officer uh old UDT guy
and so he I'm underwater and he just he
doesn't he doesn't like hit me and start
rolling me he just comes down and knocks
my mouthpiece out and then he goes up
and he comes down and and as I'm putting
it back and knocks it out again and then
as I'm putting it back he knocks it out
again and as he comes and put it so I'm
getting like a quarter of a breath each
time by the time I suck the water out of
the tube and all this stuff and this
goes on for 17 minutes and I'm not I'm
just I just keep dealing you know
getting no and then he just comes down
and pulls me up and he's like you failed
you looked uncomfortable down there and
I was like dude I was so bummed and I
was you know but what are you going to
say you're like cuz I came up I feel
fine he's like well you didn't look fine
you looked uncomfortable and I had
literally stayed you know the slant of
the pool where it goes from 4 feet I I
had only taken like one step forward so
I was right there the whole time for 17
minutes and pool comp was only a half an
hour long but at 17 minutes so pulls me
up he's like you you failed and and you
know go to the wall and so I failed and
I ended up passing it the next time but
you know fast forward 20 years or
something or 17 years or 18 years and he
now we're at trade at together and I'm
the trade at o y see and I was like hey
man you remember failing me in pool comp
he goes oh yeah and I Go why'd you fail
me he go I was just [__] with
you I was like bro that's jacked up man
this is like my whole life and I could
have like freaked out and gone into some
downward psychological spiral and he's
like a you've been fine I was like okay
that was the real test for you ja that
[__] was not cool I was like yo what are
you
doing uh so you get through second phase
no Factor third phase Island well
actually
was the yeah um yeah and that was uh
that was interesting um yeah Island
wasn't you know just okay think
tactically and they're teaching his
stuff and you just kind of do it but it
wasn't really training us like like I
tell you know it was like hell week with
a gun yeah honestly that's what it was I
mean hell we did uh uh surf passage on
the rocks out there you know by birdshit
rock you know with ibss in third it's in
second phase I'm like what are we doing
out here and um we did full I don't know
if you they were still doing this the uh
the full UDT cast and recovery and and
obstacle loading you know so we're down
there and the obstacles were at like 23
ft I'm like bro yeah hey everyone this
is not an obstacle at 23 ft no boat's
going to hit this we're good they're
like oh well you still got to blow that
[__] up still got to get it and the
weird thing about buds is you never have
you're never it's kind of like going to
an MMA fight you're never going to be in
perfect shape so in buds even though
like oh I can hold my breath for a
minute and 48 seconds you get to buds
now you have like you always have a
little bit of a cold and some kind of
weird lung thing and nose full of snot
so your breath is always shitty your
breath holding is always shitty so going
down to 23 feet to load an obstacle
you're getting like one half of a knot
each
time check oh yeah yeah that's um I I
went down on one and The Surge was was
really good it was at 20 ft plus I get
down there I'm like wrapping my legs
around the horns and I'm tying this knot
and I'm tying this knot and then all of
a sudden I don't have to breathe anymore
I was like oh I was like well but that
was a symptom of something but I
couldn't think of what it was right then
cuz your brain's already like and the
knot was like it was there but it wasn't
you know good one I like okay and then I
some bubbles came out of my mouth and
went up and I kicked off and followed
the bubbles up and uh the next day I
know I was laying on the on the the
Zodiac well no no I Zodiac Zodiac was a
long way off I was just laying on my
back and floating and I was warm and the
water was like 50° but as the oxygen
came back in I was like oh yeah so did
the the cold you know but yeah had I
been caught if I I yeah you know they
bunch of guys have gone to the some of
those breath holding schools mhm
and it really helps them a lot and
there's there's like
a there's like a knock at the door like
the first they teach you like oh the
first knock at the door like you want to
breathe you don't need to listen to that
one the second one you don't need to
listen to that one the third one pay
attention cuz you're about to black out
and and you know when you do it you can
feel it and they learn how to get
through those things but it's it's
definitely guys improve their breath
hold they'll like double their breath
hold in three days by learning
what the real signs are and what they
can push through and what they can't
push through so it's pretty cool I've
done a little bit of Wim Hoff method
that's you know then that increases but
you're relaxed at that point you're not
like trying to tie a knot on a freaking
jab
Skully yeah yeah which is so useful now
but and honestly while I was the warn
officer there the third fade training
officer they they wanted to get rid of
it out of training I was like dude well
what are you going to call the
school basic underwater demolition oh
yeah yeah that's right and the thing
about it is it's a really it's a perfect
exercise for like little microcosm what
you're going to do with the rest of your
career you're going to plan this thing
you're going to do a dirt dive you know
and then you're going to take this into
this hostile environment and execute and
it's going to be different and you're
going to have to figure some stuff out
and it's it's so much of the SEAL Teams
is learning and
training to have an open mind and to
figure [__] out and I was talking to a
guy the other day that's you know int
type scenario and he was like I don't
focus on this or focus on that or focus
on something else and I was like hey
this the training that you're going
through is to make everyone be able to
look at a problem and figure out how to
do something with it and it doesn't
matter if that problems in the mountains
doesn't matter if that problems in the
desert doesn't matter if that problems
in the jungle if it's in the city it
where that problem is you're going to
learn how to look at that problem apply
our basic tactical principles to it and
come up with a solution and that's what
you're doing and all your guys are doing
that too so and you know a good example
is when when uh seals ended up doing
security for the Iraqi government like
none of those guys had done that
specific Mission before got tasked with
the mission like okay we're going to
figure it out they made it happen and
kept those guys alive for a long time uh
I was just talking about this with with
Bobby
Holland we you know we did over a
hundred Urban sniper overwatches in
raditi in
2006 and
yeah I was like you remember how many we
did in workup and he goes uh zero we
didn't do one but we did we did uh
whatever rural sniper o or sniper hides
Recons and so the principles we just
took those principles okay yeah well
here's what we got to do here's we got
to set up we got to make sure we have
good security be in a good spot check
our our you know Escape Routes and we'll
be good to go and that's we just took
that and applied it to an urban
environment and you're good so that's
what it is and that's one of the best
things about the SEAL Teams is you you
learn how to solve problems and you take
the fundamental tactics that we have and
you can apply them to any situation and
we started doing in training out here we
started doing key leader engagement
training right so you're going to meet
with a key leader of a village and the
first
platoon we we're putting guys so guys
had started doing this overseas and now
we started training guys to do it back
here and the first platoon that did it
they were kind of confused like well
what should we do and B guy looked at
him and said if this was a Target that
you were hitting how would you set it up
they like oh we'd have security over
here and we'd put this over here and I
was like well so you're going to meet a
guy it's the same thing do you want to
have security yes where would you put it
same spot okay great so it's the same
thing it's just a a little bit of a
different posturing when you roll into
the target instead of rolling in guns up
ready to kill people you're rolling in
there you know weapons down ready to
shake some hands and and meet and greet
some kiss some babies and it's all good
and if something goes south no Factor
take you half a second to turn things
around so that that that mentality of
looking at problems and really training
and what you're talking about uh
obstacle loading something that we did
in World War II but it's a skill set
you're going to work together with your
friend you're going to figure out how to
do it it's hard it can get confusing you
have to coordinate with the other people
because you got to tie that whole thing
together just a big it's a b basically
and I've been saying this a lot when I
talk to companies right now it's
everything you're doing is is basically
a big team building exercise that's what
you're doing oh we're going to work
together cuz if you and I are going
through land Warfare together and you
think you should do something we should
hit a target one way and I think we
should hit another way now you and I
start like arguing about it now we're
getting the fight and you got your guys
on your side and my guys the platoon's
falling apart and so we're testing the
team to see if they can you and I can go
you know what coach your idea is better
let's go ahead with your oh cool and we
can figure it out we move forward it it
it it identifies the Egos and it
identifies the the the fissures in
platoon when you put him in these
situations and it happens in a class but
that's so much of what the sealed teams
is is can we as a team look at a problem
and apply our fundamental tactics to it
come up with a solution go execute and
and that's actually if you think about
it that's actually what we're kind of
good at yeah and the reason we're kind
of good at it
is if you can figure out how to get off
of a ship with a Zodiac boat with four
zodiac boats transit for 14 nautical
miles drive across or insert swimmers
have them swim across in wet gear come
across unw waterproof all your gear set
up your bre like there's so many little
problems that have to be solved by every
go hit a Target capture somebody have a
life jacket for that person and a dry
suit you can swim this person out
through the like there's so many things
you got to figure out and and if you can
do that in the water everything else is
easy every you take take me in a heilo
take me in a vehicle take me on foot
patrol that's all a joke compared to
saltwater 6ot Seas sand Mayhem like it's
a disaster that surf zone is I mean you
know oh yeah look it's just couple lines
of surf yeah and I'll drag all this
stuff through there I mean you know um
and it never stops you know but
that's that environment right there
that's what puts you
in that it's the worst place in the
world to actually have to get across and
and do it you know if you can't solve it
with technology you can just solve it
with you know planning and and you know
just guts and just go do it um and and
we did it enough over here we got a lot
of lot of beach space and a lot of surf
here at uh on the on the Strand and man
you just learn so much you know going
through that and you know okay it's big
surf all right so what's the best way to
get get through Big Surf you know and
then you you figure it out and it's
going to Tumble you you're going to be
all screwed up and then finding your
guys getting everybody back together
again I mean not everything's like that
that cool commercial where they're like
oh yeah there's Footprints and then
they're gone you know it's like no no no
yeah yeah the reality is there's one set
of footprints there godone no one knows
where he
is when we started getting away from the
water a little bit so like mid War right
uh you know all of a sudden in in UL in
training like all of a sudden the the
marops goes from four weeks or five
weeks down to 3 weeks down to two weeks
down to like a week and some people be
like oh you know we're losing our
ability to work in the water I said hey
we'll get it back like if the if the war
turns and we got to get in the water
again hey the first night that a platoon
goes out and does OTB they're going to
be a disaster and then someone's going
to be like hey we need to have
waterproof signaling devices oh yeah so
that's what they learned that night then
the next like hey we need to make sure
we have long toe ropes in case someone
gets stuck inside the surf zone and
that's like a little here's a little
detail you have a couple Zodiacs you put
really long tow ropes in them like a 100
yards and somebody can swim out a tow
rope to the other boat you can tow the
other boat without having to go in the
surf zone those are like they'll learn
that lesson day four right and all of a
sudden you fast forward you put them
through five weeks of marops and what
they'll have done is they'll have taught
done what we just talked about which is
they'll take that problem set they'll
apply fundamental tactics and they'll
make stuff really they'll they'll get
good at it again and that's what that's
why I think like our breachers are so
good our snipers are so good our our jxs
like our guys just get into stuff and
they just keep peeling back layers until
they get it to its core principles and
then they just build it out so that's
the mentality that we get and some of
that comes from loading obstacles at s
Clen Island at night that's what it is
dude Jack uh so you so now you graduate
Buds and what year is it um this would
uh be early like February uh 87 so
what's going on in the world well um not
much not much at the time um you never
know but what what did happen um is the
Iranians started shooting silkworm
missiles at uh at the uh shipping going
through the straight there uhhuh oh
that's right this is when the um like
they put the barges out there y did you
do that
well the guys who man the barges left
unit one in the Philippines and went to
man The
Barge and that left a hole there so I
had just got into this platoon right you
know so where' you go team five team
five and uh we were doing our our workup
and yeah it was August so I I got there
in February and in August
they deployed us no kidding no Trident
damn yeah um just over to unit one to to
basically sit in that place and and be
that that that check mark you know how
old are you at this point uh
20 damn yeah oh that's right cuz you
came in right out of high school then
you spent a year yeah doing jack just
but so you're still pretty young I mean
20 years old freaking outstanding yeah I
had just turned uh 20 when we started
buds um so yeah I was still doing that
um what was your job in the platoon were
you H Gunner were you a point man well I
couldn't be a point man cuz I was a new
guy so security and um so that kind of
helped out with everybody and I was like
the Intel guy so I had to the the
Blu-Ray machine was up and all the
pencils were sharpened and you know cuz
I was a pH right oh you're the Intel guy
all right cool yeah being the Intel guy
in a seal platoon sounds so cool when
you're an Intel new guy like you're
literally sharpening pencils like
where's the freaking maps and this is
why I got good at other stuff because I
was always helping somebody else you
know ordinance always needs you know
someone to help you know move the guns
and count the guns and you know whatever
prep that kind of stuff um air when that
happened I'll be in there you learning
to pack shoots and whatever else and
building ducks that was a big you know
group um you know deal anyway but we
were I was I was still going through
back in the in those days you went to
buds 6 months long and then you get to
uh uh your platoon and you had 6 months
carrying your little pqs book around
your performance qualification standards
and I was on you after a day of work you
know going the airloft hey chief uh can
you sign me off here oh yeah sure no
problem just empty my [__] cans and uh
sweep and mop and then we'll talk like
damn okay and that's how you kind of you
had to make that happen you had to get
those signatures and then you had to get
the your your board at the end of that 6
month months and that's how you got your
Trident I I think that was the same for
you right same with me yeah there was no
seal tactical training stt stuff at the
there was no sqt nothing that we had at
team one I went through stdt so I showed
up there and we didn't have our Trident
but we immediately not immediately but
after a few months they let a couple
rounds of new guys show up and then they
put us all through stt seal tactical
training and it was basically like
a limited platoon workup but we went and
did air we went and did land we went and
did marops so we did everything they
just gave us a higher level gave us some
actual kind of the model of what sqt is
it is what it is what well SKT is
awesome now but it was a yes it was a it
was neoy version of that but no we
didn't get any of that damn none of that
went to N9 with my platoon and uh yeah
you just had to kind of figure there was
no training going on it was just you
know you were you figured stuff out as
you went along and I think part of that
we've lost a little bit that because you
know the guys are TR like you know um
thoroughbred horses from you know boot
camp all the way up they know they're
going to go to the teams and you know so
they're giving a lot of stuff um back
then I
mean my idea of seal prep should be like
okay here's your workout you make it
happen no the yeah whereas these guys
are like they're showing up in the
morning they're getting their workout
they're get which is good you'll learn
how to do stuff and you know maybe not
you know injure yourself um but you're
kind of missing that selfstarter yeah
you know because you had to do that if
you had six months and if you didn't get
that done and you didn't get your uh
your board done or you failed it um you
had one more chance and then you're gone
so I mean yeah so we did that you know
in in the
Philippines
you so so you go on deployment you're
back filling these guys that were over
in the Gulf um taking care of the the
oil platforms is generally what they
were doing yep and and you're you're
you're on your how long was that
deployment that was a it was supposed to
be a short one but um heard that before
yeah well we got in some
trouble we went to uh at the time they
thought the Philippines was going away
so they're looking for other beaches
other places so we went to this little
island called palao and um I wasn't even
in this fight but my platoon was I was
sick as a dog and I didn't go out that
night um and so that big running with
the local
um so I'm I'm banned for life from the
island of
Pala me and the rest of my platoon but
so that that caused some issue um you
know they we got home from that one and
then
immediately um there was a uh a target a
real world Target that was supposed to
have silkor missiles on it wait you came
home from deployment no no we went back
came home from
back to the pi back to the pi and
immediately get tasked with this uh this
target that's that's moving silor
missiles yeah I mean that that
um uh you know the first Charlie Sheen
movie you know Navy Seals that where
they go and they they get on the boat
and they that was that was us that was
our uh that was you supposed to that was
what we were supposed to be doing we
were going to VBS at sucker and uh so
they they flew us out there and
meanwhile the Admiral who was kind of in
charge of this area he really liked the
pans oh and he would he went to the the
CEO at uh you know unit one and he's
like sorry they're on a secret mission
this Admiral did not like it was the
wrong answer so uh yeah he was real
motivated to uh to hammer us um and uh
yeah so anyway the the the op came down
to the last minute and Reagan decided he
didn't want to you know do any you know
high seas piracy or whatever um so they
solved it another way not us how like
did you load hilos did you oh well okay
for three nights we you know like okay
if we're going to wake you up at 2
o'clock in the morning if if we don't
wake you up at 2 o'clock in the morning
then just you know come up at 700 and
have breakfast and we'll talk about it
and for three nights it was like that
and we were doing runs and you know just
and again you know CQB is in its infancy
and we're just you know we're figuring
stuff out how to oh we're going to land
here fast rope on this part of we had
pictures of the boat and ideas of
they're like what is that is a gun in
placement now it turned out it was a uh
fire hose or something no no it was a
swing set because on the the the the
list of people on the on board
apparently there were people that
brought their
kids you know as part of the they work
and bring their transport well I don't
know what the hell but yeah I was like
what the hell is that thing look like a
damn no it was uh playground equipment
did you get your Trident while you were
overseas then yep yep we got a try itent
overseas um and um and then well after
all that came back we went back to Pi
and then uh they started the the the
hammering of us um over the incident in
palow and they would send guys back um
like okay the platoon's going home and
then they said well we're going to send
the the married guys first so they'd go
and they're like no we're going to keep
you guys so we they had us they were
interrogating us every day
over I know I think there was some
alcohol or something that we had brought
with us to the it was some trumped up
horse crap but
anyway so yeah this would this went on
and they're like okay go to the pool
study for your uh your TRD until 1600 if
we haven't called you then you're you're
you're good so from like 10:00 until
1600 we were at the pool you know
studying our our pqs books and whatever
else um and then 1,600 roll around we go
out in town and drink our faces off MH
um and they finally got bored with that
and you know it took a while um but we
were the last two me Jeff Payne um and
like two other guys uh and our chief
Fred Swanson that who had helped me out
earlier who was the chief of my platoon
um they basically had to drag us Kicking
and Screaming onto the bus to send us
home cuz Pi was um it was magical place
and um so we went to xoi for that one
and uh as the me and painter in the back
and we're getting read the ri act by the
uh the EXO and at the end he's like but
I feel that the extra time that you had
to spend in the Philippines was
punishment enough and I'm looking over
side eyeing each
other yeah yeah anyway but that was my
first platoon and that that put the
hooks in it was like it had everything
it had party in the pi it had a real
world mission even though it didn't you
go go down it was like no this is this
is me I'm staying and uh so you're
rolling your next platoon yeah um so we
rolled back um Team five had put in a
gym okay they didn't have any you know
they little weight Locker or whatever
but now was full on gym so I was like
okay it's time and I started lifting and
I went
from 143 lb to 175 lb in about 6 months
yeah every I was like 22 whatever I
every time I walked into that gym I left
you know I I walked in I could lift more
than yesterday it was like yeah and you
know that's nutrition yeah okay I drank
a lot of beer and microwave burritos I
mean that was the yeah but you're 22
years old you're freaking dud basically
your whole body is just a big
testosterone producing machine yep yep
and then boy jacked I put it out man and
it was like yeah boom just got bigger
and stronger
not faster always kind of sucked at
running but you know whatever um yeah
then we got uh did you step up to be in
point man in your second plon second
platoon Point man um and it was an ARG
so okay get some got to ride the ship
what ship was it uh we spent time on the
Denver and the duth oh I did a whole
six-month appointment on the USS Denver
probably slept in the same damn
compartment we did yeah wait was it 117°
yeah that's the one yeah right at the
water line so a splash you know bing
bing bing all night long yeah it was us
yeah yeah and it's funny cuz like
regular Navy guys they've got a job on
that ship we're just cargo you know so
that's when you really learned to like
drink your motivation juice you know
like oh coffee up and then go lift or
whatever you had otherwise you just sit
in your rack going oh my God you know
what the hell's going on here did you
hate it um being on the ship sucks yeah
um going different places I mean we hit
you know Australia and Hong Kong and you
know the Philippines a couple times and
Japan and Korea and you know so there
was a lot of you know stuff that we got
to do dude my first so my first point I
was with you or I saw you we hung out I
was in Guam right that's was my first PL
and I was 21 years old and it was you
know you're basically you know you have
this fat prum checks and you're doing
whatever you want like we and that early
time in Guam
we had great relationships with the
police we had great relationships with
like locals it was all it was just like
awesome we do everything hang out it was
great and then I my next deployment was
an ARG platoon and I was an E4 and it
was like E4 back on the ship by 10:00
like there was almost no rules
whatsoever in Guam when I was 21 so now
I'm 22 Yeah and they're like you know E4
is back on the ship by 10:00 and I'm
kind of like hold on bro you know what
are you talking about I'm I'm in the
freaking come on and they're
like does that does that ID card say E4
cuz if so
2200 I mean in in Guam we weren't even
getting warmed up at 2200 the party was
starting at 2200 so now they're saying
oh you got to be back on at 2200 but I
found a good way around that I'd go out
I'd bring uh my running shoes and my
shorts and a t-shirt go out till
whenever come back at 5:00 in the
morning go on a two mile run with that
backpack on that was filled with my
going out clothes come running back up
to the you just went for a run cuz the
change of shift was whatever like six so
yeah I left at 530 just did a eight
mile your breath smells a little
alcoholic was from you know from
2200 yeah I got to run that stuff out of
my system man I'm sweating it out just
freaking dummies uh so so you're on this
ship anything happened on this while
you're on this freaking shipboard
deployment buch no nothing nothing
really that mentionable I mean there was
a couple little things that that were
everything you know the spin-ups that
happen but um yeah nothing um so that
was the first half of
1989 and we come back our gear is cut
getting taken off the ship uhhuh I come
back into uh into work one morning and
uh the executive officer calls me in I'm
like oh [__] what's going I'm I'm
expecting you know a problem he's like
uh hey coach can you be ready to uh
deploy again in like 6 hours and I was
like I looked at him like well let me
think you let me go home and get my pool
queue and then I just moved my stuff
from the incoming pallet to the outgoing
pallet what had happened is uh guy got
hurt or something yeah yeah not really
hurt he uh last night all he had to do
was not get in trouble
and he gets drunk steals a bike has a
fight with the cops in cornado and he's
in the can and he can't deploy so I
get hey here you go oh yeah you were the
Intel oh yeah yeah you're first
lieutenant guy now okay awesome you're
doing Motors like okay yeah I can do
motors yep and that's what um yeah
that's how I got my second my my first
or second two deployments were back
toback basically I spent 10 days of 1989
actually in the United States and went
did a spec ops of tune um in the
Philippines for uh for that six months
yeah like
woohoo I I was at I'd been in training
cell so now I was at team one done three
deployments and now I just got put in
training cell and of course no wants to
go to training cell we want to go on
deployment and the master chief of the
command comes down and at quarters and
he's like hey we need two guys to go on
we need two guys to go on deployment
like tomorrow and me and my running mate
we're just like hands up like didn't
even look at each other just we were
roommates we're just like hands up and
the freaking master chief that was in
charge of trade at was like [__] your
[__] ha down and then you know we
proceeded to get our ass chewed like you
guys are in freaking Trade Air you're
not going anywhere we were like all
right hey M they just said you know like
they just said they needed someone to go
on deployment like us two have our [__]
in Cruise boxes right now we're ready to
roll right now there's nothing better
than being that kind of e dog at a team
when they're they're like we need
volunteer your hand is up where are we
going don't care send me well let's go
let's get it on yeah I didn't have
anybody to had to call at home to you
know hey honey is this N I was like I
let's go let's do it that was that was
the good attitude that that I mean the
higher ups they they noticed that stuff
it's like H he didn't even he didn't
know what the hell that was he's like
[__] I'm I'm game like all right note to
self if you need somebody go to him yep
that's 100% it man and then what do you
do over there on that deployment was
that went uh did the volcano go on that
deployment um no that was the next one
uh this one was the uh um the
revolution okay in pi yeah so what was
going on with what was that like so
Coran Kino she was the wife of the it
was it's politics and the pi is all
screwed up but yeah they decided they
were going to do a coup on her and um so
we we were there and we were um kind of
locked down on the base uh the guys
there were guys that were training with
the fil Mars it wasn't our platoon
another platoon they were over on Green
Beach and uh when this came down they
were like just quietly took all their
guns cuz they didn't know which side
they were going to be on you
know um yeah but then we uh we got ready
our mission on that one was going to be
uh if she requested extract from the
palace we had to go get her so there you
go back to the surf zone right figuring
out figuring this stuff out so we're
going to have to drop a boat because
there was no place to land a helicopter
where the palace was but across the
river from the palace there was a ball
field so we had to figure out how to
drop a a duck basically in the river get
it inflated and get it over so we could
Ferry her and like her bodyguard over
here it was like nobody else and us and
then we're going to combat laom and you
know fly out well no one ever done that
before you know the the limp duck is you
kick it out and it takes you 15 minutes
to get there was no time for that so we
figured out how to do it we just uh
honeycomb the crap out of a full
full-blown duck or full-blown zird only
one you put it on a uh a big piece of
plywood and uh you know tied it all
together keep it all together and you
went out with your stuff on and your
flotation but um you know um so Brad
Cooper he was the air guy and he he came
up with this and the co asked him he's
like can we do that he's like oh yeah we
do it all the time he's like okay cool
and so we do this on a dry run and of
course I'm the you know I'm the first
Louis guy so I got to be the first guy
in the in the the boat to uh to get the
engine started and uh so I'm the sea
anchor cuz as the helicopter's hovering
at you know five knots or whatever and
they kick this thing out the rotor wash
would have just blown this empty boat
away so they I was holding on to the
line as they kicked it out I was like
yink and I'm like head first boom into
the water climb up the line get in cut
the lines get the motor down by then
every the other guys have gotten close
they pull a uh um the pallet basically
from underneath get the thing started it
was like 3 minutes and we were running
and we could do that with two of them
and right after that Brad's jumping up
and going I knew he could do it I knew I
knew it would work
and yeah so now it's um they U they do
that they practice those now so anyway
so you guys are on standby y did you
ever get the call no never got the call
we stood by we bounced around we were
ready to go um there was you know a lot
of lot of moving parts that was our part
of that was was going to be that um some
other guys were going to go when there
was a
uh oh a highrise that had um journalists
in it and they were going to take that
down you know land on the roof and just
clear it to you know but none of that
ever came through they um they worked
out another uh another way but you were
spun up for a while dude yeah it was
spun up ready to go it was like all
right chomping up the bit let's do this
let's do this and you come home from
that one what's next another plon yeah
another platoon I dropped into um was
Delta platoon at that point and um in
the first jeez what did we do do uh we
did a a night night combat equipment
jump um on February 14th
1990 static line static line in the
desert out here where Amigo DZ okay and
uh um so when I hit the ground my left
ankle snapped and I was out of the
platoon and uh I mean I I got out of the
airplane you I had a lot of twists and
stuff I'm I'm bicycling out of that
getting all that stuff going on you know
you got to get the combat equipment off
of you MH I never did didn't get there
by the time I was getting to that I was
I was seeing the uh The Horizon come up
like oh here we go and I hit and it
snapped boom right there so I'm laying
there I'm like and immediately I'm like
oh [__] they're they're going to you
know they don't know where I am it's
night you know so I'm I'm yelling hey
I'm over here I'm down I'm hurt you know
I'm and then Dan gets over like hey
coach quit screaming you [__] get your
ear out cuz I couldn't hear myself like
really really
loud so the doc gets over there and he
cuts my boot off and uh and he's like
he's poking at it he's like oh I don't
and I go to lift my leg up and my foot
stayed on the ground my leg came up and
he's like oh oh don't do that and so as
everybody came over like hey what's
going on what's going on hey check this
out like stop doing that you know yeah
so I got pins and plates and all that
crap so it took a little while to um to
get better and right as the golf war
was kicking up so I missed going I I
just got my cast off um there was in
fact there was a guy I forget who it was
that couldn't go with their platoon I'm
like oh I'm in I'm in and I'm
like master's like coach you can't even
stand up you know yeah but we're not
going to do anything right away I'll get
i'll get better I'm I'm good he's like
no so he had to he put me down for that
one and uh and then I uh got another
platoon right away you know and just
started the
workup um and that was when Peno blew up
okay you on deployment for that one y
what was that like dude um it was funny
you hear this thing you know the the the
Rumblings and like oh yeah there could
be a you know volcano I was like okay
whatever um you know thinking it's a
long way off and it was um and the wind
normally went from Subic the other way
so it was going to push all the ash away
from us anyway right
so it's rumbling the V volcanologists
are oh no this is going to happen so
they move all the Air Force guys from
Clark just descended on on Subic Bay uh
and you know brought their cars and
parked them on the ball fields and
everything was like and then just raided
the damn PX so that you know they it was
like Locust showed up you couldn't get
toothpaste or anything else and when the
when the the mountain blew up it was
during a typhoon Moon so the wind
changed and blew everything our way so
it was like concrete you know little
just falling down sticking to everything
um and of
course you know um the American
buildings were built like bomb shelters
so they could you know handle we figured
it was probably about 40 or 50 pounds
per square foot damn that was yeah cuz
we cleaned all that crap off the uh off
the roofs with paddles we wore them down
to Nubs
you know just in case it was going to
happen again we didn't know but town was
was not built for that mhm you know
everything it was like just collapsed
yeah collapsed so because this is going
on we're like all right nothing for us
to do so we went out in town as this is
happening right so you're drink like as
ashes are
falling well I mean what else you going
to do right go drinking did no one say
like hey this is going to be some kind
of a big natural disaster was it kind of
like oh there's going to be some ash no
big deal it was a tyano quake man there
was earthquakes there was lightning that
was orange because it was igniting all
the stuff that was in the air um and it
was at noon it was dark like midnight
and you guys were like party
time yeah like what else you going to do
man like Guam you have you know the
typhoon parties right it like but he was
like all right so we go out in town and
um you're drinking in your favorite bar
and you hear some creaking and grinding
and you're like hm you need to run
outside and the bar collapse the roof
would just come in you're like okay well
I guess uh Rolling Stones is done let's
go to Slims you
know yeah and we spent some time out
there doing that and um yeah uh the the
next day the next time the sun came up
um it was hard to navigate cuz all your
landmarks were gone um even you palm
trees were just like peeled down like
like bananas any any Palm FR that was
horizontal because it was wet it made
this stuff stick and just it the weight
of it just tore everything down 100y old
trees just you know the the branches had
fallen off there were people getting
killed um nobody that I knew but like
out in the Villages where like B stuff
collapsing and was there a humanitarian
disaster that you guys had to be like
help out no well the the what we came up
what they they came down with it for us
to do was clear all the the Ash off of
the buildings so there wasn't a shovel
so we used our paddles and we just you
know scooped that off just so that there
would be less weight on there you know
we we did Officer houses we did uh the
barracks we did there's the big mission
bro yep working all day just that's the
big Miss
yeah yeah and then they figured out that
hey you know and we had just gotten back
from Australia they had a good Australia
trip right and then uh or no that wasn't
Australia that was Thailand even better
right um and then this happens and then
they go okay well we we we're supposed
to be worldwide operational we're not
cuz you couldn't take off you know U the
the dust was eating the uh jet engines
okay so what they would do is that once
they got the runway cleared off they
would basically tow
your plane to the you know CU you
couldn't run it you know it couldn't run
the engine you know to taxi so they
would tow the airplane to the the the
base of the runway and then they'd wind
it up and go and that was okay right
that wouldn't damage the engines too
much but that wasn't good enough for
being this worldwide capability that we
were U you know supposed to have um so
they decided to move us to Guam and it
was my platoon they got moved to Guam
and that's you know that wasn't the Guam
that you remember MH that was the Guam
prior to that when there was like
nothing there nothing there there was no
no unit no debt no nothing they set us
up in an abandoned building and we moved
all our crap in there and we just you
know it's just basically so they could
say that we had a capability um but yeah
we were we were just out on our own it
was and it was just your platoon just my
platoon yeah uh and then there was a a
team one platoon that joined
um and
uh you know but they did like separate
stuff they were you know whatever they
did theirs we did
ours but you we were just sitting there
waiting for the the balloon to go up
living in open Bay barracks and it yeah
it sucked and so the pi gets shut down
you finish that or is that when you're
when you were in Guam you're like hey I
wouldn't mind coming to the unit that's
coming over here or did that did you get
fallen there there was no there was no
unit um and there was no idea that that
was going to happen you know they were
no idea they were they've been talking
about moving the unit for years you know
so whatever um so I got back off that
diplom I was like I'm going to take a
break I'm going to go to the Philippines
and hang out for two years and and work
the you know the uh at the
unit and I got the
orders and then they switched the unit
to Guam so my orders said Subic B
Philippines but uh they didn't you know
yeah I I went to the uh went to Guam for
two years and that was um what was your
job I was the current operations petty
officer I was E5 I was you know dude
that's insane dude I was E5 for seven
years cuz I was not a rate Grabber I was
like I I want to you know show up with
my gun and my bomb and let's go to work
you know um yeah so I mean we did we set
up targets for the team oper what' you
say operations current operations p p
officer yeah that is freaking awesome I
know and what do you do uh well uh I
write some stuff down and you know and
again it wasn't that hard so I you know
worked out all the time and you know I
led PT because it was more fun than just
you know just doing it on our own cuz we
had to you know three days a week you're
out there like well I'm out here so I'll
do the counting and yelling and what
ever and um now he just do what we do
for those uh two years it uh you know we
set up targets for the you know when the
guys deployed out there we'd set things
up for them and all that so you know
unit stuff yeah we I know when I
deployed there as soon as we got on the
ground they like gave us a Target and we
had to go hit it was a training op but
they gave us the target we had to come
over the beach we had to go up in the
kill house you probably set it up we
went in there shot a bunch of balloons
or whatever and pretty cool you know and
then that was that we got ready for
whatever exercise was next but yeah
that's when I first remember running
into you and I just remember you being
you know there's a lot of guys that
would have two three four platoon that
would kind of
be uh it's one thing for a guy to be
like an [__] to you CU you're being
an idiot which is not only
understandable it's actually Justified
but then there's some guys that would be
[__] cuz they're [__] and like
you were a guy that was cool and you'd
like teach and like hey you should do
this or hey try this or hey come over
here just like give good guidance to a
younger group of guys which was me and
my buddies so I always remember that I
always remember you you having a good
attitude and and you were like uh doing
what I think it's Tony Tony AR fratty
says like just being mayor just like
just having good relationships with
people whether it's the cops the
bouncers the girls like you just could
kind of man maneuver and know a lot of
people which is an important thing
building relationships that was that was
my actual job you know the current
operations I was like okay that's what I
did at work but yeah I mean whether it
was you know the bars in town you know
all the all the girls would you know
hang out at the beach so yeah you get to
know their names you get to know the
bartenders you get to know the bouncers
we worked with the cops you know we
trained with them in the with the the
kill house so I mean we could do no
wrong you drop a drop a name like
everybody knew this a for name but he
was like famous on the island and he was
like their big SWAT guy so I got pulled
over a bunch like get a police escort
after you get pulled over yeah yeah if
you build good relationships you don't
act like an idiot because eventually we
seals wore out their wel welcome there
pretty bad I think they've recovered now
but the other side of my job there I saw
was to help the teams out I I want to
make better team guys and I know from my
experience of just being thrown into
stuff and having to figure it out that
kind of sucks you know so that being
able to pass what I didn't know that
much at the time but I knew enough that
I could you know I was you know I had
what four platoon under my belt so you
know I did what I could to make anybody
that would wanted to listen yeah that
much better yeah and that's that makes
an impact you know on a guy like like I
said me and my buddies that were kind of
Knuckleheads and we all wanted to like
be better you know our attitude was like
we wanted to be good seals that's all I
ever wanted to like I want to be a good
seal so someone can show me something
about shooting or someone can show me
about breaching or someone can show me
about whatever I wanted to know cuz you
don't know Jack yeah and so I always
appreciated that that attitude and I
would love to tell you that I really did
a good job of that and I will say it I
did that I I was too much of an [__]
if people weren't doing good I was a
little bit too much of an [__] when I
was younger you know like my second
platoon my third third platoon I was not
you know if you were jacked up I was a
real [__] and so so were all of us
you know we just had that bad attitude
uh but we also really wanted the guys to
get better so when there was a good guy
we would like invest we what it is we
care we just cared about the teams and
cared about the platoon and we wanted
the platoon to be awesome and so when a
guy was doing guy wanted to know
something we' freaking we we didn't go
home you know what I mean we didn't go
home we didn't have anywhere to go we
didn't have anything so oh you want to
do more runs cool we'll stay here and do
more runs oh you want us to show you how
to set up your gear cool we'll show you
how to set up your GE but if you wanted
to go home or you're you didn't want to
take the time to get your squared away
you were like an
enemy and and I was mad you my me and my
buddies we were like mad at you because
we were in the freaking team this was
our family and now all of a sudden we
got someone in the family that doesn't
want to carry their weight they like
well this is a problem and I probably
went I instead of like nowadays I would
have been better at like saying hey man
here's let me show you how this
works if you do show up without your
gear squared away that tells us that you
don't care about what's happening do you
care about what's happening yeah I care
what's okay so part of caring about
what's happening is make sure you got
your [__] squared away I would probably
be more like that now back then I was a
little bit more U you know of a dick
yeah age IM maturity man I mean you
learn how to talk to people and and get
the effect that you want you know and
the effect is like I want to make this
guy better if he's not going to listen
he's not going to listen but you've got
to give it that that best chance cuz you
come in hard yeah and remember he's a
team guy too and you know you just start
butting heads where if you come in a
little softer and like hey here's what
we're seeing and we don't like that you
know so fix this please and you know and
here's how to fix it you know y you know
give yeah you can't say hey don't do
that it's like here do this instead yeah
yeah yeah so I I definitely had some
growing up to do in that respect I have
had those guys I mean because of course
they all stay on the teams they're all
and we all became friends and they you
know I'll see him at the reunion or I'll
see them wherever at a memorial service
and they'll be like I'm so glad you guys
were like that you know they're they're
fired up now but still could have been
better you know could have could have
done a better job and I I wish I picked
up more of that from you than I did but
you know I also had influences you know
there was other guys that were like
that's how how it's rolling like you
this is a family this is you know in my
mind like we're counting on I'm counting
on you to keep me me and my friends
alive you're part of this we're all
keeping each other alive and there's not
even war going on by the way this is
just like me being crazy but it's also
like what the job is yeah and and you
know the guys that put me through
training most of them were Vietnam guys
and so that was big I was like no you
know you have to do this you know um
there they came from the war MH you know
so it was like you know yeah you're
you're going to be there for your your
buddies and this is why everything you
know they say oh yeah it's all our our
Sops are Written in Blood well no
kidding they are
but guys tend to forget that and you
know it becomes more personal you know
so it's not you just being you know
screwed up like oh yeah we're going to
no you got to be ready for it though you
yeah it's a def it was a definite gang
mentality for us
for me and that crew of guys and you
know all the guys cuz that crew of guys
of new guys that in that platoon when I
was over in gu when you were there we
all stayed well a bunch of us stayed
together and we were tight and we stayed
together for three straight platoon and
so you know and a bunch of us we went to
buds together so it was like you know
seven years of 24 hours a day yeah doing
[__] together so it's us against the
world you know that's what you end up
with and if you're part of the platoon
you know that means when we're going
we're going that means when someone
calls you at 3:00 in the morning like
hey we we're going people get you got 15
minutes like where are you at oh you
don't care about
us gets hostile yeah and and better or
worse I never had that every time I
moved I moved the the guy I did the most
uh deployments with was Jeff Payne he
was my first my second and then he was
while I was in a platoon he was doing
the
seal oh support debt you know says D
whatever the hell it was so he was over
there at the same time we just weren't
doing the same stuff so I I kind of was
just and I never had that that click
yeah to you know to hold on to yeah I
hate to use that word click but I use
the word gang it was kind of a click too
to be all if we're going to be all keep
it real around here yeah I don't know
though do clicks beat the [__] out of
each other if they step out of
line but we we had a great time and and
even even those you know my second and
third platoon like the guys that we were
with were just we I still talk to them I
still see them like when I see them
they're fired up you know so I guess it
all works out in the end but I from like
you said a more mature scenario being a
little bit having a better understanding
of building relationships and cohesive
teams being more positive is a better
way to go yeah yeah it's hard to
understand that when you're 22 but
that's how we
man uh so you're over there in Guam for
a couple years and then you screen to go
out to the east coast and and go through
selection you get picked up yep I um did
my screening and yeah that that was it
it was like okay cool off you go and I
was looking for a fight you know I figur
okay the I felt I felt jipped honestly
because I missed the go four yeah you
know I was like damn it you know but you
know my leg was broken long before there
was any Rumblings you know um so it
wasn't my fault but I was still felt
like I missed something so I want to get
into a fight and and the best place to
get in fight was over there y so yeah I
threw my hat in the ring and uh yeah
rolled out
um showed up uh and the training officer
for selection immediately hated
me straight up I'm like and I'm not used
to that I'm not used to hating me I'm
like here I'm you know coach whatever
and uh no he your nickname coach is very
fitting like like your nickname suits
you really well like coach it's coach
you know he's here to coach he's here to
help out it's coach you know that's what
I've always thought a coach so that's a
weird that's weird for somebody to hate
you out of the gate dude yeah and he
hated me and I know cuz at the end of
training he's like
coach you know how much I hated you I'm
like yeah I know you didn't like me very
much like no no no no no ah I hated you
what was did he tell you
why I was too happy okay okay I was too
positive but you he just had this Buck
of his ass about me and he tried to
Poison every everybody else in the Cadre
you know and uh I had to work so hard D
I mean um I hate you cuz you're too
happy freaking he just hated me yeah my
attitude was just like I'm was like
happy goluck yeah yeah cool man I'll
show blah you know
hated it hated it and um so I had to win
over all the the Cadre you know whether
it was like Pat try was big into Muay
Thai and stuff so I was his punching bag
I got out there and just and I laid into
him he beat the snot out of me but I
kept coming back and so oh got a thumbs
up from Pat and uh Markley not the one
you know that um they're both gone now
but you know I had to light him up with
simunition cuz he figured I was going to
be looking you know in the hallway not
where I was supposed to be when he came
through the door I wasn't I was looking
right where I was supposed to be and I
lit him up thumbs up you know so I just
had to do that for everybody and then
you know survive you know 6 months of uh
of selection and um yeah so that that
was a that was a rough time and
selection is it's just like buds they
put you in that same scenario except
there's a lot of at the time a lot of
alcohol involved you know you had to be
up you know drinking with the Cadre
buying drinks and then being ready to do
whatever we were doing whether it was
diving skydiving or shooting the next
morning so yeah that was that was the uh
the intent back then I guess well
luckily you at least did some
preparation for that in oh yeah my my my
liver was uh was in in in good training
you know
yeah and then so you're out there you
you got you were out there at that
command when the Bosnia stuff was going
down yeah so that's pretty that was
pretty awesome at the time right yeah
that was like our our best thing the the
the piff Wick operations a Personnel
indicted for war crimes so we're
basically kidnapping people off the
street how good how cool was that it was
awesome that was give us a rundown like
how' it go down um okay the one I talk
about um he called himself the Serb
Adolf and um just voluntarily giving
yourself the name the Serb Adolf all
right you get the down check homie yeah
dude um but he wasn't High Enough uh a
rank to have anybody helping him he
didn't have the Intel the higher ranking
guys had Intel and they would know when
we showed up um so we went over there to
catch these guys and we did some stuff
and couldn't find them and I'm like okay
so we pulled back and then went back
over but this time they shipped Us in
shipping containers oh nice so yep
forklift brought in your hanging on the
the Trojan Horse they call it little
straps to hang on to you know and they
they wield you into the uh the big
clamshell you know hanger closed it up
and that's where we lived for a couple
of weeks and uh yeah we end up um we
snagged that guy and had another guy
that was uh a dry hole who obviously had
enough Intel to to know you know
something was going on so they bugged
out um but yeah that was uh that was
cool we did that
for were they like low viz Ops where you
like roll out in civilian vehicles and
stuff yeah civilian Vehicles civilian
clothes everything you know you have a
bunch of guys um you know the guy
driving the van would look like you
would you wouldn't pick him you know
long till you open your mouth you just
look like you know one of the locals
yeah um but the back of the van was full
of ass eaters with you know you know
have her mp5s and full kit just ready to
go you know it's funny we were still
using mp5s back then isn't it yep it's
freaking crazy yeah dude uh when did we
get the the cqbr that would have
been late 90s early 2 99 2000 I can't
remember exactly when but yeah we
basically turned in everything except
the the ks and the uh and the SDS what
do you think about this recommendation I
I don't know why I stumbled upon upon
this idea but you know people always say
like what's the best weapon for home
defense what should I get for home
defense how about that MP5 for home
defense weapon you know yeah
honestly it would be good the biggest
problem with it is nobody knows that
manual arms your manual arms is M16 yeah
M4 okay that's where you know you know
where the charging handle is it's
automatic and that was like the biggest
thing when we went to the MP5 it was
because princess gate had happened and
the SAS had them so everybody who was
anybody in the you know hostage rescue
you know realm was carrying an
MP5 um but would have been smarter hard
for us to do was going with a cult
Commando and 9 mil cuz all you know but
it wasn't as cool you know but the the
MP5 if you if you're a normal person and
you're like all right I need a I don't
really have a weapon for my home defense
and I need to get something the MP if
you're going to learn something for home
defense okay how much does one of those
cost well they cost a lot yeah like 25
three grand you know for anything
worthwhile um what I have for home
defense um I made a 9mm AR okay so you
agree that having a 9mm platform like
submachine gun rifle type yeah is a good
choice it's a good choice for most
people The Recoil is low and then so I
built a special one cmmg makes this
radio delay blowback uh you know system
so it's kind of like the roller delayed
but it's you know different but it keeps
everything nice and light radio what
radial delay radial delay yeah thing's
pretty cool and I took an 8 in rifled
barrel and found a an 8 in uh we'll call
it a high volume linear compensator it's
basically a supressor with no guts in it
right and I pinned and welded it right
so it's on there so it makes 16 in which
makes it a rifle so it's California
legal whatever and it also because it it
directs all that Blast away from you
towards the guy you're you're throwing
lead at you can shoot this thing without
air pro it's loud but it doesn't it's
not going to ring your bell it's not
going to give your wife tentis and you
know deaf and your dog or anything like
that it's you know but it it shoots a
decent round and you know that 8 in you
know the Germans they always uh you over
engineer everything yeah that the uh uh
MP5 Barrel is 7 Seven Something inches
long like okay this one's 8 in I think
that's optimized for 9 we'll go with
that yeah and then I added that other
piece on the end so that uh to make it
legal is there anyone else that makes
this recommendation what do normal
people make recommendation for a home
defense weapon you
know you you ask 10 different people you
get 10 different answers but shotgun is
what they uh they come around with the
thing with a shotgun though I mean
obviously you can't shoot as accurately
with a shotgun as you can with the thing
that I always remember the thing I loved
about the MP5 is you could just drill
nails with that thing you could put
round after round after round after
round through the same freaking hole you
can do that with uh with the one I built
too and it has AR you know uh function
right um how's the reliability it's been
fine nice it's been and I put it
together myself I mean I you know I'm
actually talking with some people to
make one commercially oh now everyone's
going to want one they're going to hear
this they're going to want to order it
up yeah home defense
freaking yeah get some but the thing so
you got 9 mil you could use a round like
a frangible round so you're not punching
through your walls and hit other family
members yeah yeah there you go hollow
points you're going to be shooting super
accurate there's no recoil they're easy
to shoot like it's a so who's going to
be defending your house is it a Navy
SEAL or is it your daughter your wife
yeah you know so that's the thing about
the shotgun they're going to take it out
they're going to shoot it once and be
like oh my God and they're not going to
train with it you have to aim a shotgun
you don't just point the damn things
plus you're responsible for every uh one
of those pellets that comes out
right the AR platform is just so
ergonomic it's so easy to use you know
um and I set mine up with a a light a
red dot sight and a sling this is a
no-brainer all day yeah yeah so you can
I can hand that to any one of my
daughters you know whatever in 5 minutes
you can have them you know punching a
little tiny group at 10 20 yards easy
day no recoil no no real you know blast
issues my wife's she's recoil sensitive
and and blast sensitive she's real
sensitive right she's a girl she's
awesome but you know that was her thing
you know she's just not not good with
that so a shotgun no that ain't going to
happen a lot of people talk pistol like
okay well pistol's good but if someone's
coming to invade your home
chances are they're going to have a
pistol or a s of shot something small
okay and if I'm going to get in a
gunfight with somebody I want to have
the upper hand and if I'm home I'm
bringing my full-on gun you know um and
we have so I've got one in that's set up
that like that in 9 mil and one in 300
Blackout oh yeah and they're set up
exactly the same so I can train with the
9 mil but if I want to throw that uh you
know 220 grain subsonic round at
somebody in case that home invasion goes
to the street son yeah kid I got to
reach out you know but yeah that's
that's just me I'm a gun guy so I was
like I think about something and I go
and build it I well yeah the thing about
a pistol for home defense and look if
it's you and me like all day of course
no problem but my wife my daughter has
to pick up a pistol stressful situation
it's night like there's Mayhem going on
you their group at at whatever at 10
yards is going to look like a shotgun
blast compared to with one of those with
a submachine gun it's like they're going
to dial that thing in it's game over
yeah and it's easy it's you know you got
two points of contact it's small enough
that you can maneuver around and okay in
in your your home defense scenario
you're not clearing your house MH okay
you're going to collapse back on the
weakest or least mobile individual's
room and you're going to hold there call
the cops and you know with the door
closed you know you let them know hey
I'm armed I'm in here and if he comes
through the door you smoke them and
you've given them for a warning um this
idea that you know maybe I might clear
the house but I've kind of done that a
little bit but even then one man CQB is
not optimal okay just FY I'm 100% clear
in the house my CQC my one man CQC is
optimal and some some people are getting
dropped yeah yeah I mean you you do you
man I mean but it all depends on who's
home and you know where I'm at and you
know what's going on
um but yeah my recommendations for you
know self-defense shooting CU that's
kind of my big Focus now that I'm not
working with the Navy anymore I want to
make Americans I want to make them um
better prepared
okay um I was going to get into this um
but um so for a long time I was focused
on making Navy Seals better I'm not
doing that anymore so now I've shifted
my focus to the regular potentially
Armed American okay now there's plenty
of guys out there that want this
information and this is was ties into
why I did the the stuff with tactical
Hive um you know and I don't know if
we're getting ahead of stuff but cool um
yeah I we do I do videos for tactical
Hive they're on YouTube and I don't hold
anything back I don't like tease and
then hey you got to come to my you know
course it's like no I will show you
everything that that I can in that 10 15
20 minute you know spot you know I I if
you watch it if you do it you'll get
better you CU maybe you don't have the
money to come you know pay me my price
to you know go shooting with me um but I
want you to come away with something
you'll get better quicker with me y you
know because I've done it for such a
long time you know when we buil that
course um at uh at
buds I put a lot of stuff stuff together
you know as a team we put these things
together and you watch it happen and you
see guys making mistakes and you figure
out how to fix it you know you reverse
engineer everything and then we started
training the the instructors that would
come in um they're only there for two
years and that's not a lot of time so I
have them ghost me and you know Watch
How I correct you know whatever the
problem was and then they would listen
to the words that we're using keeping
everything you know Common um and then
in in no time you know they could fix
about 80% of the common problems guys
had so it was a big fa Force multiplier
and I look at that I'm like all right
how can I shift this over to just
regular folks and you know the regular
Marksmanship train Closing one eye line
up you know front side F that doesn't
most people if you want to learn to be a
Target shooter yeah go do that but I'm
going to teach you how to point shoot
first two eyes open cuz two eyes are
going to be open in that stressful
situation and you're going to have to
deal with you know using natural point
of aim and and and you know spend enough
time on your grip so that it naturally
points to where you want it to even
without looking at the SES because you
ain't going to be looking at the SES
you're going to be looking at the Target
you know because that's where the in you
the interesting information for your Li
lizard brain is right it's like that's
the danger spot so you're going to be
looking there so instead of doing like
we went in buds we had the first week
was all Marksmanship training and the
second was combat shooting and so I've
taken basically the the the first week
off the board and just do wave tops of
the second week and and get you started
there and you know I can make you better
um we've been teaching cops I just got
back from uh Chicago teaching or
Illinois little town called Rockford we
did uh we're post certified there now so
ni we can uh we can teach the uh the cop
CQB and think the difference between
SEAL Teams and cops you know the big
difference is we train all the time yeah
they don't that's not where their money
is their money is you know on the on the
ground doing the job and almost no
training yeah which is terrible i've
been I've been for the past many many
years I've been saying police should
train 20% of the time and if they did
20% of the time you know so it's one day
a week or maybe that's two hours a day
like however you want to break it up but
they would be so much better cuz right
now like that group that you just
trained how much training are they get
in a year in tqc none there you go how
much how how many rounds they shoot in a
year uh the guys are having a you know
they get like 60 rounds paid for I mean
so if they want if they want to you know
get better on their own 60 rounds so
just so everyone that's not like a
person that has shot weapons before 60
rounds a year for training is not going
to make you a proficient shooter in a
normal situation in like a flat range
situation yeah well that was just for
for the qualification not training so
thinking that you're going to be you
know have one of these you know we
expect our police officers to be able to
handle these crazy Dynamic especially
right now crazy Dynamic situations where
things are going on people have all
kinds of armament they they do crazy
things thinking that a police officer is
going to be ready for that just because
they've been on the job it just doesn't
make sense and we're really we're really
failing not only failing our police
officers but we're failing our civilian
populace as well because more often
times the police officer that's not well
trained doesn't hand a situation right
and it ends up terrible and you can tell
so clearly when a police officer's
trained they just respond infinitely
better than someone that's not trained
so I'm going to I don't know what else
to do about that uh hopefully we
continue push that message and and
people will say well they need to be on
the street right no well they need to be
out there they need to be out there that
so they don't have time to train okay so
let me ask you this would you rather in
your
neighborhood have 10 cops that haven't
trained
patrolling at you know at 2 o'clock in
the morning or one or midnight or
whenever would you rather have 10 cops
that have trained two hours in the last
year or would you rather have eight cops
that have trained you know 20% of the
time anybody that has any sense at all
will say I would take the eight guys
there's no doubt about it I would take
two guys instead of I would take two
guys that are well trained over six guys
that aren't well trained the problem is
that you know the guys paying for it you
know they're in charge of the train
they're like they have to have these
guys on the street you know they got to
fill that schedule but that's what I'm
saying somebody needs to say hey having
an untrained person on the street is not
worth that savings they just don't they
just haven't figured this out yet and I
don't know how they haven't figured it
out cuz when we do have these negative
incidents happen with police officers
it's most of the time any Common Sense
person with tactical training will be
able to say oh yeah if this would have
happened they would have been able to do
this and the problem would have been
solved and we watch you people like
people like you and me we watch those
things and we're like it's it makes me
sick it makes me cringe because I know
20 minutes doing deescalation procedures
would have solved this problem mhm you
know a half an hour on a mon Day morning
going through hey think through this
problem let's let's walk through it a
couple times you come up in this
situation what are you going to do well
I'm going to run up and start yelling at
him okay well let's think about that
what if he doesn't respond the way you
expect him to well you know most of the
time when I yell at a guy tell him to
get down he gets down okay but is that a
great first move how about we get some
cover how about we yell from behind
cover now you got some time to react now
you got some time for decision making
now you're got some distance between you
so all these things that you can teach
really easy and then you got to drill
them you got to drill them but look what
I just just said you could do that for
free that doesn't cost anything takes 20
minutes let's run through the scenario
talk through it and then let's do it and
then you have a guy come up come upon
someone that's causing problems and
instead of running up and yelling at him
yay get down cuz like they get trained
to do that from working right cuz most
of the time when a cop yells at somebody
they go they don't want to get arrested
or they don't want to get in trouble so
they obey it's that 1% of the time yeah
that the person's on drugs they're going
crazy they don't care they want to die
they want to kill that person is the one
we're worried about the person that you
yell at from behind a car and be like
hey get down and they get down cool
we're all happy when you yell from
behind a car get down and they don't do
what you want them do cool now we have
other decisions that we can make we have
escalations that we can do we're in a
protected position we don't have to
freak out we have time to react there's
all kinds of things that we can do so
those basic training protocols that
aren't happening right now that's what a
lot of these problems are coming from
very seldom do I see a a video of a
police officer that has that that
something has gone South where you can
you say to yourself oh the intent of
this police officer was to have this bad
situation happen Norman's like oh their
intent was to solve the problem and they
did not have the tools and the training
to get it done which is a freaking
nightmare yeah and I I love training
cops okay um but honestly as much as I
can you know you know they got to pay um
by doing these videos for tack hiive I
want to train everybody I want to give
everybody that you know that the
situation awareness you're talking about
is not that hard and you can you can
train it you know just you know distance
gives you time angles gives you a way
out and then just keeping your head up
and on a swivel you know and if you can
remember those three things you know the
guy who's looking to grab you or you
know treat you as a victim that Predator
is not looking
for a hard target they're looking for
the easy Target and if you're doing
stuff you're looking around you're not
you know everybody's you know in their
little private phone booth you know
staring at just if you got to talk on
the phone bring it up in front of your
face rather than looking down if you do
that you're not going to have trouble
most of the time in those transition
spaces and everything else so I mean you
know that kind of training and then
here's the next level because that
firearm that you know you're carrying
all that does is gives you an extra
option it's not I'm armed so I'm going
to go do you know I'm a sheep dog and
I'm going to involve myself no no that's
just you have to deal with all these
other you know uh like the escalation
deescalation figure that out and if
somebody pulls a gun on you and they've
got a gun on you you are not I can't
outdraw them okay you got to figure
something else out you got to wait for
your time your opportunity Y and you
just how did you get yourself in that
situation you know what I mean how did
you get someone get close enough to you
and you were lacked situational
awareness that they identified you and
that they were able to pull out a weapon
without you being able to create
distance and and get yourself into a
survival scenario that's just a lack of
awareness and it's a lack of training y
so and and then it's the gear as well um
you know these days when when Co hit you
know you couldn't buy a gun cuz they
were just all sold out you know
everybody who who didn't have a gun went
and panic bought something you know
there's a bunch of stories about that
it's like oh yeah give me the Gun Show
loophole you know how much more I got to
charge for that you know um and Studies
have shown that if that guy bought that
gun came home put it on his coffee table
and stared at it and was like and got no
help from a gun guy he's now more
anti-gun than he was before explain that
they're afraid of it still it's like
they bought a rattlesnake and brought it
home and they they because they have no
idea what is now it's a gun in and
they've been told oh now I'm 20% more
like or 80% more likely to be you know
killed by a gun in my house because I
have one and so what do they sell them
yeah they normally sell them or put it
away or whatever but if if the other
group same guys you know probably voted
well for stuff like this but now they
need a gun cuz they you know the cops
aren't going to come there to to you
know save them in their toilet paper um
yeah if they had somebody in their life
that was a gun guy that could help them
out that gets them past that first you
know step okay I bought the gun now what
well no get some ammo let's go to the
range here's how to hold it here's you
know those are those guys are now way on
the other side they're on our side now
you know we're um the the armed citizen
I mean cops can't be everywhere but
armed citizens can be okay we just need
more of them more guns equals less crime
if you have the right people you know
that know how to use the gun so my
latest thing um I
uh doing tack I've stuff I got noticed
um by this company called lipes and they
do special limited edition guns and
stuff so I've been talking with them
about taking out the um the roadblocks
for civilian gun ownership okay you
can't change it from the other side of
the law but on this side guy buys a gun
okay now he wants to carry it so he buys
a holster well now he wants to put a
light on his gun ain't going to fit in
that holster anymore and it just it if
you're not a gun guy it's a big pain in
the ass so what we're planning on doing
and I think this is going to happen
early next year
they're going to come out with I think
Smith and Wesson first um the coach
Edition uh you know uh I think there's a
couple revolvers and then we do some
autol loaders I don't know exactly for
sure
but but what comes along with that when
you buy one of these they'll be a little
code that you can go on the interwebs
and there's going to be me explaining
exactly what you got in this box and how
to use it why we made the decisions on
the grip and the sights and everything
else and then when you decide you know
that you wanted you know after you've
taken to the range and got some some
rounds down and some reps now you want
to carry it well there's going to be
ideally there'll be a little drop- down
menu you know inside the waistband
outside the waistband Red Dot light and
everything will fit together so it kind
of takes that uh the guesswork out of it
I mean I got a box of freaking holsters
that I don't use some of them I bought
some of them w't given to me right but I
if you're not a gun guy you
know it's just that much more of a pain
in the ass to to deal with right and if
you can just buy it in a package and
then have somebody teach you how to use
it you know and in person is always
better y but if you can go over okay
this is how you stand and this is why
and here's where your natural point of
aim is and try these drills and you know
I think that's going to be the best way
for me to uh to expand this and and get
the uh I want people Americans to be
able to defend themselves cuz cops can't
be everywhere and you know don't be
afraid of the uh equipment you know know
how to use it and it takes the fear out
of it well now we're going to have to
make a uh
9mm cult freaking AR based freaking
submachine gun for the house Home
Defense that's what's coming next yeah
the actually um yeah well through this
company Lipsy they they they can work
with anybody anybody in the gun industry
so yeah we'll be pushing something like
that um and yeah coach branded I mean I
had to come up with a color and a logo
and all this stuff like really
man yeah I I never wanted this you know
um hopefully it's just a big smiling
dude yeah yeah I mean when when tack
hiive when it started um my buddy door
he uh he was still active duty so he
came to me I was like hey uh coach I got
this opportunity to like do this you
know video channel stuff you but I can't
be on camera you want to help me out I
said
no the last thing I want to be was that
guy in front of the camera um he like I
know it's really easy man just just
you're basically teach a class to this
little you know Asian guy in his little
Filipino guy and his brother you know
and his videographer is going to you
know shoot it I'm like video who's got a
fing video
he's got a videographer um but anyway so
we did that and did a couple of them as
his journey cuz he wanted to he was a
big BJJ guy and uh he he realized that
if somebody shows up with a
gun okay he didn't know what to do so he
wanted to find out DJJ is ineffective in
that scenario yeah against against
Firearms it's uh yeah has its limits um
I love Jiu-Jitsu but yeah doesn't work
against a gun very well so that was it
he wanted someone to film his journey
and then you know so we did a couple of
those and then I they found out I had
all this gear cuz when I when you you
know you improve your gear you get new
stuff I would just take the old stuff
off throw it in a bag and went in my
garage so I basically have like gear
history from you know the late 80s
through the early 2000s and door's kind
of the same guy as me he's you got
everything from you know the you know
late 90s early 2000s all the way out to
you know he retired last year so he's
got all the all that cool kit and dude
those videos get a lot of hits because
people love gear yeah they do um but
yeah so that gave me that you know we do
training videos we do uh Gear reviews
and uh firearm reviews and uh and
basically Gear History um but there's a
big problem with YouTube um they uh they
hate guns oh yeah so we've got like over
400,000 subscribers we get fewer hits
now now than when we had less than
100,000 so doesn't make any sense so
we're struggling with that at the moment
but um well they you probably just
aren't getting into the algorithm yeah
there's there's something man do you
like do you do do you do any pure Gear
videos we just talking about like I saw
one of your videos was like about cold
cold weather you know the the PCU does
that get more because it just get in the
algorithm or anything you know we did we
did retro um like training techniques MH
and we do it with a 45 and it got like
400,000 views in a couple of weeks I was
like cool so we did like a bunch more
and they get almost they got like 20
30,000 here and they're like okay that's
nowhere near what this one did so
whether that's algorithm whether it's uh
you know just the fickle nature of the
audience I don't know it's weird it's
weird I don't even think about that
stuff because I think it's uh too hard
to comp comprehend what's going down do
you think about that stuff K do yeah
absolutely is there can you make sense
of it um so there are strategies to
improve how your videos perform on
YouTube for sure a lot of that has to do
with what people initially see how that
first pool of people react to it
clickbait 100% yeah oh is is it an
engaging title of the video what's the
description like what's your thumbnail
image look like all these things that
contribute to whether or not somebody's
going to click on that thing in the
first place and start watching it then
how long they watch it all that's
contributes to how it factors into the
AL algorithm and then how it's delivered
to a wider audience based on the
engagement it's getting so there there's
a lot of strategic a lot of stuff going
on stuff just make cool videos that's my
recommendation cool videos 100% that's
what we're trying put out good
information you know help people yeah
and then you know then nobody looks at
your backlog it's like you know like
okay we got a thousand videos cuz I'm
I'm I'm not an owner of the that website
I'm just a subject matter expert that's
been there for four years now from the
beginning um you know and since then I
this whole electronic realm you know
come up I'm like all right so uh um
practical Firearms instruction that's my
website if you want to come train with
me you go there and then what is it
practical pral Firearms PFI yep yep
practical fire instruction.com maybe
she's short that to just pf.com you be
able to get that somebody already owns
PFI try to charge you 5 million dollar
to get pf.com that much I do know yeah
and then um you know I'm I'm kind of
branching out my wife's like no you
should do your own videos I'm like okay
so she just made me a YouTube channel so
PFI coach on YouTube is going to be
that'll be me there's no videos there
yeah you can look there now there's
there's nothing but it's like we're just
uh start filling stuff out let me tell
you you better get some up it's Coach Co
ch right yeah Co and the reason I did
that is because if you know you write it
like a coach you know Co a then when
they write out my whole name it's coolo
it's like no I'm no just Co plus I could
trademark that one Co is tra trademark
to me there you go um you know just it
was part of this whole deal like oh
we're going to put coach on a gun so
okay better get that Tri marked and you
know and I got ideas all the time so I'm
thinking about a smartwatch uh band so
you know Commando bands I got a
trademark on that one we'll see what
yeah I I want one I don't know what it
does but like I'm in the game let's get
that Commando band rolling and that 9
mil AR
platform people going to be hype on that
one like you know I get my algorithm
will have all kinds of shooting stuff in
there and and I don't see that very
often people recommending a like a
submachine gun for home defense and I
think it's a great solution well
effectively it's not a submachine gun
cuz it's just going to be semi-auto okay
so you know it's not a machine gun so
okay what what's the proper terminology
then a semi-automatic pistol caliber
carbine is what they're that's the new
right thing so the PCC the PCC good
thing for the home defense yeah I mean
all basically it's going to save your
ears you know when it comes down to it
um and you know
it's we'll figure it all out I mean I
you know people coming my my brother
who's on forging fire and he made some
cool knives he's been on there three
times oh really we like going to do a
collaboration knife but you know he's
he's an artist so he's up making swords
in uh in Oregon I just got to get up
there we got the the initial design it's
been sent out for years I'm like come on
we need to do this thing right now I got
I've seen like advertisements for that
it just dudes out they're just hammering
on metal right making cool stuff so Nick
my brother your brother yeah he's the
only one he's the one next to me next
down from me right so he's two years
younger than me but to this day he's the
his sword is the only one that's cleaved
the pig in one go this big you know big
nochi you know armor splitting you know
Katana you know samurai sword and it
just hacked it Bo like cool does he do
the whole process like folding the metal
over 10,000 times whatever yeah I mean
there's there he could tell you all
about it but yeah yeah he heats the
stuff what does he do for a living
that's what he does for a living but but
you can't just be on that show for a
living you got to oh no no no not okay
so at the time he was uh he was a a
steady cam operator okay and when covid
came around it killed that so he's
unemployed from that but by then he had
been you know the society for creative
anacronismo and beat beat on each other
with sticks in tournaments oh oh yeah
it's it's pretty cool live steal and
everything else but so he speaking of
gardener like you know out in Peto have
you seen that stuff yeah the petero war
yeah my brother came down for that one
yeah they go out there and it's just
like dudes in freaking armor rednecks in
armor just getting after eating the [__]
out of each other well Nick didn't have
a lot of money to buy the armor so he
started making his own and then that
branched off into making swords and now
he makes just absolutely beautiful works
of art you know and he's selling them
and that's how he makes his yeah he's
making his his liming is uh is selling
you know belt jewelry basically to uh
people CU they're way too nice to F you
know dude people are like you know he's
out in the bar and the girl's like what
are you doing he's like I'm a freaking
sword Mak
what's like what up yeah and she's
either like I want to marry you or like
get away from me yeah you sicko yeah no
he's good to go he's married he's got uh
his whole business is you know he moved
it all up there and he's got a big shop
and 16 ton press where he just you know
he heats the stuff and he's on Facebook
um Nick coach Nicholas coacho I'm not
sure look him up look him up but yeah so
we we've been talking about doing this
collaboration with him and it's just you
know it it takes some time you know
before he moved to Oregon and everything
else you know Home Defense Katana Home
Defense
katana was the last time run through you
know had on the corner yeah he was run
through not gunshot wounds yeah
check where were you on September
11th um I was at uh at Dam Neck and uh
we had the um we had a three-letter
agency that was there with us training
um and we were in the
um uh in the high Bay and uh it was we
didn't know when the first plane hit but
when the second one did they came in and
said hey guys you got to look at this so
we came in and we you know they replayed
it a bunch and these guys they packed up
and headed back to Washington and uh
they were actually on their way when the
plane hit the uh the Pentagon damn um
yeah so we we just basically sat around
watching the TV in the team room going I
called the wife said uh things uh be a
bit going to change yeah we had no idea
and actually um uh my particular group
um we didn't go to Afghanistan first we
went to Bosnia one more time cuz they
didn't know they didn't know where
things were going to go so they sent us
over there cuz there was some Rumblings
or whatever so that was the first place
we deployed to for a month or two MH and
then uh and came back from that and we
were the second group over and uh into
Afghanistan we did our our three-month
deployment doing um high value or high
value targets was was basically we were
focused on so Elvis sightings and you
know whatever um Elvis sightings yeah
intel was was you know sketchy at the
time so you're just like spinning up
looking spinning up looking yep ready to
go flying off hitting a place you know
and um you know of course bunch of dry
holes you know cuz we didn't get him we
you know and they didn't have the whole
hierarchy of uh you know the bad guys
yet um and it was on one of those um it
was actually the last the last mission
that we're doing in that three months um
they advertised a uh tf60 awesome guys
but they're like oh yeah 20ft rope and
we'll put you right in there okay cool
so I didn't have my big gloves on my
sexy shooting gloves on and that turned
into a big Fiasco um they pulled up
short I was
in-3 - one pulls up short
-2 damages his airplane missing him
because we're like 800 yards short of
the actual Target and what he thought
was whatever he stopped here anyway all
those guys they did a crash landing you
know Dash two does a crash landing Dash
two t crash line dash one put its guys
out y okay onto a Target that's 800 yard
800 me short of the actual Target and
apparently it looked similar for I don't
know exactly what the dis the deal was
but y it's coming in hot yeah it's nuts
all right so we got guys on the wrong
target guys on the wrong target crash
bird and the bird's going down guys are
like you know un undone ready to go rope
in hand and watching the you know Canyon
walls go flitting by in their little you
know Green toilet paper tubes and then
uh that pilot found the only place in a
square mile that he could put down an
h60 and uh you know that when when the
60s uh rotors are turning they're nice
and flat as they slow down they dip a
little bit and when they dip they start
hitting Boulders and just busted them
all up so they're dealing with that we
watch dash one puts out their stuff I'm
the last guy off of Dash three the last
bird and then we had a 47 we the the
idea was they were going to come in and
we're get a foothold you know control it
and then bring in the main force with
the
47 anyway so I'm looking at this thing
and I'm going this does not look like
the pictures you know and I look down
and it's 100 foot rope and there's maybe
20 feet on the deck and you know and the
last time I look down there uh the Rope
was going right to the center of that of
this little square on the roof mhm so I
zip on there you know hot hot hot you
know I hit the ground I throw the rope
away and as I'm reaching for my weapon I
step back well I thought I was in the
middle it turns out uh my heels were
right on the edge of the roof so when I
stepped back I step back into
nothing and I know the last thing that
goes through your head before you die
because that was that I mean and it was
like I was just really disappointed I
was like [__] they're everyone's going
to think I'm a jackass yeah and then you
know bing bing bing things start
happening um and then and it stops and
I'm like oh [__] I'm not dead you know
and um apparently um had I fallen off of
uh two sides I would have gone one story
down where I fell off I fell two stories
but I hit the edge of the first story on
the way down and spun me around and
threw my gear all over the place that
other Edge it was about at least 100
feet before there was anything that
would stop me so there's your frog man
luck right you know take it not good
enough to to not get hurt but uh good
enough not to die so I'm laying on my
back uh when I hit my Camel Back burst
so the guys look down and they see see
me laying there in a spreading pool of
black liquid and they're like okay Coach
is dead how do we get off this
thing so I get my crap back together and
I'm you know uh there's an animal pen
next to me and whatever is in there it's
like you know really pissed off I'm like
oh crap this cow's going to come out and
stomp me this made of sticks you know
and I'm laying in front of a big
uncleared Breezeway on this you know
made of Boulders and and Timber I'm like
okay I can't stay here and wait for the
backboard so I did a quick systems check
and I got my [__] together and made my
way over so I could look up on the roof
and make coms with the the calm guy up
there and say hey look I'm I'm I'm good
got my you know nods back on but I I
can't move my my leg is jacked up my
back feels like there's someone poking
me I actually looked behind me like ow
what okay no one's poking me and and my
shoulder was jacked up as well and my
face cuz when I fell on the my nods
tried to mhm poke my eyes out but for
some reason because I I want to be able
to see so I I would always wear clear
eye proo under my nods which wasn't a
common practice but because I had those
Oakleys on um I'm still able to see with
two eyes because it would have poked
them right out um anyway so when they
finished clearing down and you know
pretty much everybody on target was uh
right inside that
Breezeway but luckily they were just
non-combatants so we were on the wrong
damn Target yeah
um so they met back me the next morning
and uh that was the last mission so then
a couple days I was back in the in the
states and they had to do a they cut a
big uh meatball off of my leg big
hematoma and then
um my shoulder didn't want to work it
would just impinge it would come up here
and just stop like okay what's up with
that and so they examine it so SLAP tear
and some other stuff going going on in
there we have to operate we had just
found out that we're going to be the
guys going into uh Iraq in The Invasion
I'm like ain't no
operation for that no ain't going to
happen so I what else can we do and what
he did is he gave me uh the dock gave me
a a shot in my arm Corone or some magic
liquid but immediately it was like oh
not in pin anymore yeah we are good he's
like okay I gave you that so you can
train we'll give you another one right
before you go out the door but when you
come back we have to operate cuz you
don't get your two is all you get on
that one and I'm like okay so that
allowed me to stay with the team and uh
and roll over and uh and do our uh
Invasion stuff and you got there when
did you get there like for the war to
kickoff yeah oh yeah well we were okay
so everybody's all the the conventional
forces were down south
and we were way up north in Saudi Arabia
the northern sa Saudi Arabia so while
everybody was rolling up we were doing
these deep penetrating missions to the
wmd sites that you know Intel said might
have this that or whatever and we were
hanging out pretty far um you know it
would have been had had Hilo gone down
it have been days before anybody could
have got to us not in a helicopter and
we had uh we had one real close call
um we all got shot up pretty good we in
47s mhm and this little town we came in
and I was in dash1 and I think we took
half a dozen rounds through the
fuselage um but then Dash two came in
that same track and they got all yeah um
one of the air crew got actually shot in
the head he survived but you know um all
our guys were clean um and so we went
and did the W wmd you know we took down
the outside just mop level four well we
weren't we had the mop suits but you
know dash one where I was uh we were
securing the outside area and then Dash
two was going to roll in they were
mopped up they were all mopped up and
they you they're like sitting there just
watching the light show the rounds came
through the f l like how are we not dead
um my my bird um the the Hydraulics got
hit on the uh the door and uh so you
know how say that ramp comes down and
goes yeah he went
playing and everybody it were running
off and the guy in front of me slips and
falls on his ass and and you know scoots
off and Mike laughing at him as I slip
on my ass and Scoot off the hdic fluid
hydraulic fluid everywhere like you know
scooting like a dog with worms um and
then yeah went went and ran did our did
the whole deal no problems well that
bird couldn't come back because the
hydraulic fluid it couldn't you know fix
it that that is get it out of there and
then the second bird had the injured guy
on it and was all shot up and so they
went back out to the desert we had a
flying spare and a qrf two other 47s
with us so after we ran around and and
this is so so deep in there our our time
was limited on on fuel so we had to do
what we did turned out it was it was a
dry hole you know thank God uh and then
we piled back in you know and we were
able to get everybody on that flying
spare and you know nut to butt on the
with the qrf you
know yeah and uh so there's this
um uh 47s have the two counter rotating
uh props right and there's a drive shaft
that goes between and then there's a
cover that goes over that well there was
a big
dent in that one on my bird and if you
were you had it hit and gone in and
messed with that drive shaft then the
that's what keeps the rotors working
together and they would just ate each
other when would fallen out of the sky
and it would have been a really really
long night for well probably somebody
else but um yeah as it was you know we
had a bunch of little close calls like
that um hitting a bunch of different
targets you know
um tracers of big guns anti-aircraft
stuff going between the rotor disc and
the fuselage of the bird you
know bro I've had some uh I've had some
Huey Vietnam pilots on here both the
SeaWolves and then just regular army
conventional like uh air assault guys
and man what they did with those Hues is
did they drove things like they were
bumper cars at the freaking uh Fair like
they's going into L's fire everywhere
taking hits all over the place just
going in they don't give a [__] man
there was three there was 5,000 Hues
sent to Vietnam 3,000 200 of them were
lost in combat damn that's those guys
were Next Level man and and I'll tell
you what's awesome the Seawolf guys well
the Seawolf guys when you talk to the
seals and I've had some you know the
Vietnam seals that that have come on
here dude those Seawolf guys were coming
like they were coming and they didn't
care and like that we had one guy in
here telling the story they they just
stayed like oh we're running out of fuel
cool they just ran out of fuel and
landed in a freaking rice Patty and used
ammo ammo cans to transfer fuel from
another bird that they brought in into
the bird like these guys were just
freaking legit man making [__] happen
but those birds too I think because they
were less
technologically uh uh Reliant they were
just more durable you know it's like
it's like having like a a brand new
freaking BMW right now versus having
like a
1967 freaking I don't know man those uh
Blackhawks are pretty resilient too my
my oldest brother is a helicopter pilot
for uh Army and uh he was actually spent
a year in Afghanistan doing dust off
stuff so it's like you know whenever
there was a tick he was on his way you
know yeah he went to pretty much all of
them um and I mean he had uh a uh a hot
LZ and uh Ground Force Commander saying
hey we got guys down here w we need to
get you down here we need to get them
out of here and uh so he disobeyed Army
Doctrine didn't wait for the gunship
because the gunship couldn't make it you
know as fast as he could he got there he
looks around and goes okay and there's
no traces over there I think I can get
in so he came in hot hell yeah and got
lit up um and as he's coming in the you
know the Army birds have the the the
wheel is way up on the tail Navy Birds
is like halfway up cuz you don't have to
you know turn them on uh aircraft
carriers so anyway you can hit the
ground pretty hard with that sucker
because it'll it'll save the the little
shock absorber right so he had to come
in hot well when they laid out the DZ
they laid out an angle it was on angled
Turf so when he hit that hard it slammed
his head into the uh into the canopy
knocked him
unconscious
okay when he came too probably just a
couple of seconds but hey you know um
didn't know he was in Afghanistan didn't
you was like you know you kind of you
know as the system like reboots um he's
like okay you know all right we're good
but the the bird didn't roll over didn't
ball up they loaded a bunch of guys uh
on there and flew out again with you
know couldn't wait for the gunships at
this point cuz they squirt the ground in
front normally and then you fly
out and so he flies out and um got
everybody back to base but when he got
there everybody was
dead every you know and so they went
from you know he was the things when you
disobey Army Doctrine and two things
that happen they give you a medal or
they prosecute you and um he would have
he would have had another air medal for
that one but because you guys got hit on
the way out and and died he KN he knew
at least one guy back there was had
jumped on to to do
CPR and uh yeah he got hit and uh and
expired on the 5 minute meal flight home
so instead of prosecution they just
called it even you know I it's like okay
yeah you you tried you didn't you know
had there had been some success there
apparently and I'm probably screwing the
story up a little bit but uh I mean he
it broke his neck um on the you know so
he and then he just kind of you
know dealt with it and um yeah he
actually like last year just got it all
cleaned out they had to go in there and
fuse his neck and take out you know the
the disc that was pressing on stuff cuz
he was going numb and you know but yeah
again he was taught by the you know Army
Vietnam you know helila Pilots back in
the day and and and he grew up on uh on
huies that was his first uh platform so
that be interesting you have to ask him
which one is more which one would which
one would do better going into a hot LZ
I mean I get I'm I it has to be the
Blackhawk but then again too those huies
man they're little and probably like you
can get in there quick and but then
again the blackhaw has better armor on
like critical components yeah like the
the the pilot titanium seat and like the
brains of the I'm sure the brains of a
Blackhawk are and the critical
components of a Blackhawk I bet you they
have better armor and some redundancy as
well yeah but anyway that's I do know I
was talking to on this podcast I was
talking to a huie pilot and he was like
yeah you know the thing is our Birds
only cost like $200,000 he's like those
Blackhawks they must cost like a million
dollars I was like it cost like 20 20
something million dollars so that's why
when one of those things goes down
people freak out they were just great
you know just go-karts with the freaking
uh the Hues uh did you did you you must
have been on the Jessica Lynch then too
if you were there yeah with that crew
how'd that go down um that was we got uh
Intel we were working on you know a
Target you know we're going to hit that
night this comes in and goes okay put
that on on hold and they flew us from
where we were to a a Ford operating base
and we sat there and got Intel that was
like you know they'd found you know the
the certain three-letter
agencies had contacts with you know
locals and they had gone in and sent
them in with h rigged with cameras so
they could uh you know identify the last
guy they sent in rolled up there and you
know walked up the stairs top of the
stairs is a big bust of uh Saddam and
gold he turned right went down four four
doors and there she was we're like all
right Proof of Life man we are going so
um we got all set up and uh they had the
ground assault for us it was going to
take them like two hours to get there
you know through Barra you know all that
stuff and 99 Rangers and some snipers
and some some of our guys and initially
we were supposed to be on the Gaff and
uh last minute they uh they oh well we
get an extra 60 all right cool so we all
got on that one and we' just been shot
up you know on the 47s a couple night
before so with this one the doors are
open you're like all right I can shoot
back now because that's the big thing
about a 47 it's like you just got to sit
there and take it you know but now I was
like no okay I got guns up plate pressed
forward we're [__] we're g to get feels
good anyways yeah
yeah and um yeah as we were getting on
we were like sitting go you know if if
we die tonight that's uh it's worth it
yeah you know cuz you you there's an
American out there and um you you know
she'd been reported as as fighting to
the last round and you none of that
really came through but you know
whatever she was in a car crash and it
messed her up really bad and they they
never claimed that they had her you know
they you know she she was she a prisoner
of war but yeah they had this cute
little blonde girl that they uh you know
whatever the hell Iraqis are going to do
anyway so we roll in there and as we're
flying in we we had coordinated with the
Marines at the uh at the brid it was a
bridge just outside of town and they
were going to do a little salt there so
that was going on we coordinated with
them as like a you know decoy and as
we're flying in look over there and you
see these tracers doing this you know
going you know towards each other and uh
we get the DC's clear I'm
like okay can somebody tell
them but they was at the bridge that was
like uh you know almost a mile away I
think um and they rolled in uh the
initial breach team dropped in on the
little birds and they put snipers on the
roof this is a seven story hospital and
we came in landed in a little uh
driveway Courtyard thing behind a wall
um and just ran up there and as I'm
running through this I'm like hey I've
seen this on TV you know exactly the
same we get up there we turn right and
clear down and there's the room she's
supposed to be in she's not there I'm
like oh crap not a dry hole come on so
we finished clearing in that wing and
you know the end of there [__] at
the end there I busted all that out and
you know looked nothing and so as we're
all right clear the other way cuz the um
the staircase came up like in the middle
of the wing so you had that one side
than the other right so as he came back
they're bringing up this doctor who
spoke English he's like oh Jesse yeah
I'll take you see Jesse no problem blah
blah blah you know and so one of our
guys had him by the Scruff of the neck
with a pistol on the back of his head
and I was left left side point man
and there was all these big Windows all
the way down and I really really really
wanted to like check my six but that
wasn't my job you know so I'm like boom
you know set it forward and going okay
relying on your uh your number
two and we get there door was open
through the doctor in just Cas anybody
wanted to me shooting theyd shoot him um
and then we entered like normal MH um
clear no problems and then uh she'd been
like laid down on the bed and uh she sat
up and I was right at the foot of the
bed I'm like Jessica Jessica Lynch and
she looked at me with the biggest
scaredest eyes I've ever seen on a human
and she was scared of me and that like
took me I was like oh [__] you know I
set her name a couple of times she was
just non-responsive just scared as hell
more guys were coming in and I hadn't
shot anybody yet so I I left I got back
out in the hallway figured you know that
was my best chance of getting that fight
anyway so so got to the other end ended
up in the [__] again same [__] on
the other end right cleared that and
that's we got thin and uh so I held
there and uh they they brought the the
medical bird in brought the dock up
packaged her up and flew her out and um
we found her in 6 minutes and she was
flying away in 16 minutes freaking
awesome yeah it was it was good um and
then when we back cleared down and
cleared the uh the lobby was full of uh
civilian and and then the the um the
basement basically there was a big sand
table down there I'm like what the
hell's this like well there had been
300 Saddam fetene you know resistant
whatever the hell you know bad guys that
went to go fight the Marines at the
bridge damn had that not happened yeah
it been a different story yeah yeah yeah
damn freaking awesome and then so what
happened after that I mean wrapped up
that deployment yeah um we we hit a
bunch of other places you know looking
for wmd uh U we hit Abu grab looking for
uh
Spiker um you know he he was still
missing at the time um so we did a lot
of that kind of stuff uh and then came
home and um when I came home that's when
uh I had to make some decisions cuz I
I'd been I was banged up I was in bad
shape uh you know my my shoulders were
all Frozen and this one needed an
operation and I I knew I was going to
have to go under the knife and I was at
18 years it been you know you I was like
well if I'm going to retire at 20 I
don't want to retire in the east coast
and if you like the East Coast great but
I'm a West Coast guy so I want to find a
job out
here so we made the deal and I came to
work at warcom um say goodbye everybody
sold the house you know I I've been
married to my uh my wife uh about 6
years at that point and um yeah packed
up everything and came out here and got
a job at warcom testing guns and ammo
and um you know Scopes and stuff you
know it was good um you know it got to
be part of the scar program and you know
help develop that which was which was
awesome um
and you know just kind of what was your
role in the scar I was the naval special
Warfare representative for the scar
program how many representatives were
there well was there one from every
Special Operations unit yeah yeah and
then you had the the Marines were just
observing MH and so you had the um army
uh Special Forces Rangers um Air Force
um you know they were all part of this
thing because they're all part of Socom
right and um yeah so everybody put their
their two cents in and I'm actually you
know kind of responsible that there was
a scar heavy because the scar light was
supposed to replace the M4 MH and
normally what you do is you take the you
know you you show up with all these
different guns and you narrow them down
to the best two the closest two and then
you take that there's money involved in
there where you test those against each
other well the scar the FN model was the
only one that didn't have a buffer tube
and as you know water doesn't compress
so if it's full of water and we're
shooting from the uh the water line the
gun's either going to give you one shot
or it's going to blow up in your face so
I said guys you know rather than you
know if we can just do this you know one
because the um the program manager had
heard me talk and he's like hey if we we
can narrow this down to one then we can
move on to the next phase which was a
762 version MH right and and I got
agreement and we uh so basically the
fact that they all had buffer tubes just
eliminated every other rifle every other
one had a had a buffer tube on it and
you know I was like well that's not
going to work from for us it's not
optimal for us this would be better um
and so they they took that money and
they put it into the next phase and then
it was up and running when they Clos
down the the scar light and because it
didn't make a enough of a uh of of a
leap forward but because the 762 version
was much better than the M14 got it they
were like oh okay so we so the scar so
the scar light doesn't exist right now
hey I think you can buy one on the
civilian Market but nobody yeah I mean
and it that's cuz it didn't have much
enough advantages over the M4 yeah that
they were just like well we not going to
change everything for this it was too
much to to change I mean you know the
thing about this how do you like it oh I
thought it's a great gun I I mean we did
as much as we could you know there's
only so so so much you can do in in uh
testing you know we tested the hell out
of it uh and we identified issues and we
corrected those issues you know so it
was it was a good platform um when it
got down range um one of the biggest
hiccups in when you field something is
that new equipment training and uh so
when the belgians put this new space
aged uh you know polymer coating on
there that would last you know shelf
life for 10 years but you got to clean
it really good before you shoot it the
first time and you know frog men they
looked at it went H cuz it's not like
cosmoline it's not like this big gooey
stuff they looked in went ah it looks
clean and they took it out and they shot
it and that stuff turns to shellac and
it causes malfunctions and that was the
big thing right out of the Bas those
thing that a scar heavy too that was a
scar heavy yeah cuz that's the one that
actually made it to our guys yeah
um but I mean a lot of that's been fixed
I mean you know the scars it's it's a
good solid gun um yeah uh I guess the
new Sig M7 or whatever that's going to
that's kind of going to take its place I
guess I don't know I'm I'm so far out of
the uh the loop at this point we did the
best we could at the time and you know
we made a a less than 8B gun that was
Modern
762 and uh and we really didn't have
that you know at the time there was the
sr25 The Mark 11s but they weren't um
they weren't everywhere this is just you
know going to be every man's gun then so
you do this kind of Acquisitions and
weapons testing and all that that was a
big deal I mean that freaking scar was
like you'd hear about it every it seemed
like every day we'd hear about what was
happening with the scar cuz everyone's
freaking got their you know to talk
about two cents man we' had billions of
dollars if we if we could have collected
everyone's two sets it was coming in
yeah up down and across and we were just
doing what we could with uh you know
working within you know corporations as
well as the the big Navy machine Soom
machine you know getting money testing
whatever what's the like efficiency
level of the bureaucracy of
that well you know now having seen a
little bit in the private sector it's
actually pretty good okay because you
still have that military you know
protocol stuff whereas in the private
sector you you don't have that so yeah
you never know um but yeah it it was
frustrating to me coming from you know
the command where you just think
something up go hey let's buy five of
them and see what happens you know and
you know CS commercial off the shelf
just buy what's what exists now maybe
talk to the guy modify a little bit and
then let's take it to work and see what
happens but that's that's not the way
it's uh it's done at the um the Navy
level yeah definitely not at the giant
like force wide systems level
cuz we there's all kinds of stuff that
we were able to get away with cs for a
while and then you got to get caught up
you got to get something that's going to
work for everybody and it's going to be
integrate with everybody so yeah yeah
which which makes sense it does make
sense it does everybody's got to be able
to talk to each other got get in spare
parts and okay yeah that's but that's
not where I was I was the guy at you
know rubber meets the road let's go do
this you know um I I explosively tested
uh Humvee armor and that saved save some
guys lives so um you know was you know
it was a good place for me be to be for
me to be at the time because I was a
physical
wreck um yeah I tell guys now it's like
hey you know when you're an asset to
your team you know stick it out man you
know be an asset when you can't be an
asset and you start being more of a
liability it's time to move on and that
was what really sent me from there uh
you otherwise I'd have spend more time
uh at the command I just would have um
but that that wasn't in the cards
because I was my knees were starting to
all this stuff was just starting to just
show up you know yeah and um showing up
uninvited dude yeah um but right as I
retired I going skip ahead just a little
bit to as I retired I uh met this guy
named Joe hipen Steel ultimate Human
Performance and he basically showed me
how
to mobilize again you know to open all
this up you know and uh I I spent a year
working with him uh and I got he was
paid for by the uh I think the the Navy
SEAL Foundation or somebody you know and
I was like no dude this is this is
awesome and um got everything opened up
again I could stand like I'd been
working with the regular PT for like six
months and no improvement and 30 minutes
of working with Joe I was like I walked
out of there going holy crap I got extra
room my shoulders well different it
stretches okay and he's kind of
unorthodox but man you feel it was it
like have you heard of Active Release
therapy was it that kind of thing yeah
he does he does that where it's like you
know you you find that that spot that's
hot and you press on it and you know
your pain scale is you know 1 to 10 10
being the worst and one being nothing
you go to like a six or a seven you can
press to an eight you know and as you
press on it you it feels like here he's
letting up but he's not the muscles just
kind of it'll flutter and do and just
kind of lets go and it's like okay and
you know and then just through the
stretching and opening that up and
getting that new blood in there that
that changed everything for me um and
then I started I'd been doing kettle
bells prior to a lot of good functional
strength there but I was still training
like I was 25 and I'm just getting hurt
and then you still eating like I'm 25 so
I was 20 lbs overweight and just you
know and I thinking okay yeah you know
I'm still gotten through this and they
did for a long time and then about oh
two years ago I found this guy called
the uh the knees over toes guy oh yeah
Ben Patrick oh hell yeah started doing
his stuff oh my God Next Level now it's
like all right I can do more stuff and
then earlier this year um Virginia high
performance uh through the Navy SEAL
Foundation those guys I went and did
their uh month program did you do the
one that's here in San dieo I'm a plank
owner on that one that's awesome yeah D
if you haven't done it dude get in there
I mean yeah I I I I I'm going to let the
guys that need it bad you know get in
there you know I'm still doing pretty
good um so but yeah I've heard I've
heard nothing but awesome reports yeah
they open things up you know physically
two workouts a day they teach you about
nutrition and then they go into the
cognitive stuff cuz I mean you know
we've taken some hits M okay um when
you're breach your Dam NE you take about
a thousand minimum St safe distance uh
explosive exposures per year I was Dam I
was a breacher there for seven years
okay now my brain scan is clean but I
still have a few symptoms I like faces I
don't man I've known you for years I I'm
not going to forget you um but even guys
that you know if I a long time you know
um so I went there for the grand
opening I'm just getting to the elevator
and I see this guy I'm like I know you
from somewhere it's Keith Davids damn
okay and he's like yeah coach we're on
gold Squadron together and I'm like oh
yeah and that used to really drive me
nuts and I you know but through working
with them you can't change that okay
but mean Keith's like manad like he he's
not a guy that's changed a lot he looks
I went through buzs with he looks
exactly the same as he did that like so
yeah and he's he's tried it zer1 he's
you know like he's kind of a big deal
these days and uh I was like oh oh yeah
okay like damn anyway but so that's
that's my big symptom there is I is I I
lose that those faces and names that's
my biggest thing um other than that I'm
I'm pretty clean mhm you know and it
used to like make me you know
get you know this I should have known
that you know I'd be pissed off at
myself but now that I understand that
that they're I've taken a few hits and U
there is that it's like I'm lucky that
it's not something that you know I'm you
know raging and and hitting people or
going you know off the rails not none of
that happens and uh when I identify that
that coming up I can just breathe
through it it's no problem we're all
good you know um yeah yeah and that's
you know you hear like the the guys that
were in the NFL or they and they
say you know they're all banged up now
and they're like well would you do it
again and they're like hell
yeah like that's but had I known this
you know this is now available to the
guys that are still doing the job so you
know I tell them hey use it you know I
mean keep being good you know stay in
that fight for as long as you can I
would have stayed longer they the next
generation's going to be uh a lot more
durable over the Long Haul because their
their nutrition's better their their PT
is better like you said man we were
doing bodybuilding or triath like there
was a bodybuilding group of guys there
was like a triathlon group of guys and
no one was doing anything that really
made like true
sense and and then you know as the
things moved along you know by the time
we got around
20002000 right right around as the war
was kicking off started people started
recognizing that we could actually be
smarter about this stuff that there was
better ways to work out that there was
better ways to eat like we start and now
and now I think the final piece is like
there's better ways to train where for
instance is it really necessary to take
a thousand breaches a year probably not
at minimum safe distance you know
there's a lot of things that we could do
you know you know I would I always think
about being like an RSO on Carl gustoff
day you know it's like oh hey let's go
out there I'm take a task unit worth of
guys out there and everyone's going to
shoot a Carl G and I'm there's three of
us rsos so I'm going to suck start
freaking of those things you got to eat
the majority like I wonder why I got a
little headache this evening you know
and so being smarter about that stuff I
think these guys their durability their
longevity is going to be is going to be
better than ours yeah and and technology
and Recovery that's a big thing as I get
older it's like okay I can still do a
lot of stuff now but I can do it once
and then I got to go lay down for a bit
you know whereas when you're young you
yeah bounce right back um I was
introduced to this thing called a shift
wave and you have to look it up I don't
know the all the the science behind it
it looks like a lawn chair with a bunch
of discs in it that vibrate to a certain
you it's they're tunable and I sit on
this thing and can I tune mine to
Metallica well it does a little bio
feedback thing so you could listen to
Metallica if you wanted to and just but
it goes off your breathing and your you
know it reads all that stuff and um yeah
I've been using it it's it's kind of
like a an active um meditation type
thing you put on the headphones and it
kind of walks you through they like
breathing in breathing out and it you
know you syn with the uh with the
vibrations and I mean you know they can
they can basically duplicate your brain
waves in sleep okay this what the the
doc was telling me I was like oh well
that be kind of cool and they built it
in this lawn chair so it's you could fly
it away it's a lawn chair with a um like
a little Pelican case that goes with it
and uh I've been using the thing for
about five months now so you like have
one in your house yeah yeah they but
they they gave you one they gave me one
to like hey man cuz all right I'm
talking to this clinical psychiatrist in
uh um tane University right and um
anyway uh
he shows me this thing it's like yeah
guess I I'm I'm kind of new age my wife
she's awesome you know she finds this
stuff you know grounding we've got a
grounding sheet on the bed I go barefoot
like all the time and and I'm I'm I'm
being in the technology with the uh the
smart watch and the the aura ring and
all that stuff that monitors all this
stuff and when he saw that I was like
huh and I've got that information that
that record so it's like hey sit on this
thing and you know just play around with
it and we'll see how how things things
go and let me tell you it's it's eye
opening you you get on this thing and
it's weird it's you know but it like
shakes you you know and then it'll just
stop and then you still feel like you're
buzzing you know it's it's really cool
um and there's a bunch of different you
know settings that you can do and and
you know frequencies it's it's badass
you know I mean look into it but uh it's
it's it's pretty cool what's it called
it's called a shift wave shift wve you
going to check it out maybe have to get
in the shift wave I don't know yeah hey
if you want to try one come over my
house I you take a little ride on it you
know and and see what's up it uh it
shakes you like you know when you're
like skydiving you get out and and
everything's like you know everything's
going you know the it feels kind of like
that but uh and you can adjust how much
how you know if you you know tone it
down I crank that thing up all the time
uh what about ice are you doing ice and
sauna or anything like that I've got a
far infrared sauna at the house and that
is the key and I my wife's talking about
getting the uh the coal plunge I'm like
well before we spend a bunch of money on
that one cuz that's just not the SAA is
like uncomfortable slowly and but it's
warm and you know yeah that ice plunge
thing it's like uh all right maybe let's
try with this just the tub at first you
know but my wife she's a she's
hypnotherapist yeah and um you know she
does guided meditations you know she got
crystals in your house oh yeah just full
on we're getting crystals oh yeah dream
catchers incense incense and smudge Bots
and uh yeah yeah he gets her all the bad
energy and you know she's she's um where
did you find her um okay so while I was
at Dam Neck I went to go work with the
uh the special boat service over there
and so she's a Brit she's a Brit you
know my wife's a Brit no I didn't know
that we're going to have to link them up
with no freaking crystals in my house
bro she can come hanging she can come
get my ice bath it's it it's all good oh
yeah yeah maybe we we TR you come sh do
some shift wave and our wives can drink
tea
exactly yeah I know but yeah she's got
her own practice and she does uh guided
meditations on uh on on YouTube so she's
you know Guided by Corey you know she
just kids meditations and stuff like
that so she's she's doing a lot of a lot
of good stuff and you know you know the
left brain right brain stuff you know
really left brain logical and she's so
right brain and just open to everything
and and I think it makes us a good mix
you know and that's uh yeah what was the
name of her YouTube channel uh it's uh
Guided by Corey Guided by Corey yeah c o
r y is her name is she talking in asrm
is that the right word voice ASMR ASMR
you know what that is yeah that that
does she have that voice she's she's
British come on man I mean she's she's
exotic away you're like oh wow you know
yeah and she's doing some other stuff
where just like it's really quiet and
just makes noise yeah she's just getting
into that ASMR type that's the thing
dude that's the thing and then she'll
just like quietly you know give you a
little little boost you know like lower
your shoulders you know all that yeah
and yeah so she's got a couple of uh you
know things set up like that so she's uh
you know um she's always looking for
that that next thing to be able to to
bring yeah I mean
bring peace and surrender to the soul to
to the soul to to anybody who want who
needs it you know everybody needs it you
know the hell
um right on uh but but before you
retired you did some time what at unit 3
went out there for a bit Yeah backing up
um I I was working at warcom and I'm
working for three retired seal Master
Chiefs and they're like you should put
your warrant package in you should put
your warrant package in I'm like dude if
I deal it with you shut up up and so I
did and they picked me up first time
yeah of course I'm like okay and that
came with a one-year
unaccompanied yeah you're going to pay
for it off to yeah and and but I was up
for orders anyway they I could have said
I could have declined you know the the
warrant and and they would have sent me
anyway but anyway we I met my wife at uh
when I was at the command so we we did
like maybe you know 3mon deployments
she'd never done a six-month deployment
and G year yeah so yeah PE her off the
ceiling and go okay honey how those
crystals work
out
yeah they they probably helped out a lot
for her mental state you know while I
was gone and of course you know you know
this every time you leave town that's
when the car breaks and the you know the
everything goes wrong y um but yeah so
she she was thrown into the straight
into the fire at that point and I went
over and uh and did my warant officer
stuff over there um I was the the the
training officer and the combat systems
officer and know whenever they needed
something done that's the warrant's job
you know nobody knows what a warrant
officer does but we just fill in all the
cracks you know yeah and yeah you and I
were running around warcom at the same
time cuz I was the freaking you the aid
and I was uh so we'd high five each
other in the hallway and you'd laugh at
me going you freaking
dork how many coins you got in your
pocket there
Jo yeah thank God it was for for Maguire
cuz he's like as you know just a great
dude but um yeah not fun but you'd be
like Oh I'm going back to freaking blow
[__] up again and shoot more guns and
I'd be like cool I'm going to write a
freaking thank you note to Ambassador so
and so go make these copies yeah go make
these copies and then you closed out
your career as a as a buds instructor
yeah yeah um so when when you're a team
guy the last place you want to go is
buds cuz you might miss something you
know and that was the last place I went
and uh I'd been overseas for a year and
then made the deals like I was going to
go back to uh to uh to buds for a couple
of years and then go to a team that's
you know the deal I made with the uh the
uh the
detailer um so I roll back third phase
training officer and I didn't have to do
any of the admin stuff that the that I
was supposed to cuz we had an admin guy
we had a retiring osc who did everything
MH I was like dude that's the so that
freed me up so I would just you know
split my time on the island with the
Master Chief and the uh and the the
lieutenant M and we got out there and
just I spent most of my time which kind
of matched up with the uh uh weapons
guys and so I do line coaching I didn't
teach any classes but you know I was
still doing warn officer stuff so I get
pulled off of the uh off the range to go
deal with VIPs and whatever else um but
I was learning how to teach at that
point um and then when 25 rolled around
um when just prior to you know my 25
years they uh had this really cool idea
Admiral had a cool idea about anchor
teams and he was going to send me to
Bangladesh for four years I was like you
know what oh look at the time 25 years
we're done and he's like are you know oh
CB you know uh was like you sure cuz you
know once you submit those papers you
can't take them back I'm like yeah I'm
good that would that's not me I I do
everything then the Navy I can't do this
I've got two daughters at home and
they're pre-teens it was not a good time
for for that um and he goes okay want a
job so I rolled out of there and I
rolled into the instructor position and
um you know we started off um and we
started immediately making making
changes um there weren't enough seals to
be buds instructors at the time okay
they want them out you know doing seal
stuff so they decided to do contract
buds instructors and then had the first
batch was done like a year before I
retired so Gordon Evans I don't know if
you know him he was at Team five for a
long time um he and I were the the the
guys uh he I and Nick white were the uh
the instructors at um for for weapons
and because we were there we were just
there the idea was like you can be there
for five years and then we'll have
enough guys and we'll just back for you
and you know send you on your way well
are you like wearing a blue and gold
full on oh yeah blue and gold
eight-point cover Boy Scout shorts the
whole nine yards what they call what the
students call you just instructor Co Mr
coach Mr coach okay y you and and it was
we wanted to make that difference
between us because when I stepped up to
a guy on the line I didn't want him
thinking oh crap this guy's going to
hammer me I want him think oh it's coach
he's going to help me all right so I was
never the heavy you know now if guys
kept on screwing up i' get oh hey so
what could you do right about now that
would make you never want to do that
ever again uh get wet oh good idea you
know go hit the dip tank you know um but
yeah so we took
this um up until then if you had
somebody who knew how to teach weapons
guys learned more if you didn't and you
guys were only there for two years so
you had a good shooter you know and
that'd be great if you somebody who
wasn't that good so you were kind of
relying on how good the class could be
right you you're the class was guiding
the schedule and how far can we get the
class and we changed that we're like
nope we're going to reverse engineer
this and on this day you will be here on
this day you will be here on this day
you know and we started writing stuff
down and trying stuff it was like a big
laboratory on how to shoot and um so you
know Gordy and I we we wrote things down
we tried new stuff if it worked we kept
it if it didn't then you know and we we
just modified we started calling the
sacred Scrolls was basically the dailies
you know and then that grew into all
okay here's the things you want to be
looking for so when we Tau the new
instructors like on this day this is
what they're going to be doing wrong you
okay and so be looking for it and this
is the corrections that we want to start
and every day built on itself we would
teach them the night before after dinner
then they would dry fire for an 45
minutes to an hour and get some sleep
and then the next morning we go to the
range and they would you know warm up
and then do what uh what they learned
the night before have lunch come back
for a range in the afternoon again more
second range there and then they come
back eat dinner and then back in the
classroom for the next thing that was
going and and we pushed that along and
we built this system whereas like when
we went through training some guys could
shoot and some guys couldn't no
everybody can shoot I can teach you to
shoot as long as you listen to what I'm
saying and do it okay if you're going to
fight me okay there's only so much I can
do I can't crawl into your head and and
control you I was talking to some young
guys um and I was basically saying hey
there's some people like you take a 100
people there's going to be a person
maybe one or two people they're not
going to be able to shoot a pistol well
now mhm very seldom when you get someone
that literally like isn't going to be
able to pass how often would somebody
not be able to like like get dropped
from buds for pistol how often would
that happen um I think it probably
happened in the 13 years I was there
maybe eight times okay so it's pretty
rare that someone gets but probably a
lot more guys would get rolled roll them
yeah we' roll them and then they would
come back and if they they still
couldn't do it and we we designed a
remediation for them so that when they
weren't on the island and initially it
was like you know you fail pistol you're
off the island like well no let's keep
them around oh yeah you know they shoot
more and so uh week one was uh or
weapons one and then we'd leave the
island and demo would come in they do
arts and crafts with explosives for a
week and then we come back and teach
them combat shooting well halfway
through the combat shooting was their
last attempt so they've got all those
extra trigger squeezes so most of the
time they would make it and if they
couldn't then the next time they came
through they would so occasionally when
guy one of those eight people well what
what what are they doing what does it
look like to you okay if I tell a guy
hey you're doing it's not like hey don't
do that I'm like no I'm going to show
you physically if I I'll put my hands on
you and say no hold the gun like this
squeeze it like this I use all these all
the techniques could but if you can't do
that if you're not applying what I teach
you and then then there's the guys that
are great when there's no stress but
just the stress of that stopwatch was
enough to just blow their mind and
they're great when they're not under
stress well that's not the job you're
applying for your guys not going to be a
good team guy dude that ain't going to
work out yeah that this is the the least
amount of stress we could possibly give
you it's a stopwatch okay nobody's
shooting back at you no one's yelling at
you just get up there and perform and so
I would tell him I like look we're
looking for that guy who can
compartmentalize who can take all those
noises in his head and put them aside
and just get to work you know just do
the job don't listen to the all you know
because everybody's got that noise in
their head that's you know overthinking
and you know you could tell by the guy's
Target whether he was an overthinker or
whether he was just sloppy you know if
overthinkers when we start give them
time drills their shot groups got better
just because they didn't have enough
time to overthink yeah you know and
those guys were pretty easy to correct
um the guys that were like really good
you know when there was no time limit
and then you give them the time limit
and they start going you know nuts you
know and everything would open up it's
like okay those guys are just trying to
they're they're racing the clock it's
like no no and I give them techniques
and they would work mhm and then you
teach guys how to move and shoot and how
to use cover and how to transition from
your rifle to your pistol and there all
this stuff that were getting un buds I
mean you know I got I picked up the gun
off the bench and shot it at the round
Target and then put it back down again
and that was the training that we got in
buds so guys are leaving Buds and
initially um in the first couple years
the new guys were showing up to the team
and outshooting the old guys nice cuz
they didn't have any you they had fewer
training scars yeah you know and we had
driven them to
this and you know we were still still
working that and it was still it it's
still working now um they're now focused
more on combat shooting earlier and they
they've moved the qual courses to later
on in training um so that's changed up a
little bit but apparently that's there's
some uh having some good results um as
well right on it so so you wrapped up
with that you retired in 2010 after you
got done with your buds career um then
you rolled right into that contract and
you did that for like freaking decade 13
years 13 years yeah yeah and I trained
you know you know guys I did platoon
with their kids came through and you
know it was that was rewarding I would
like you know maybe take a picture of
them and just randomly hey what's what's
your dad's phone number you know and
just send a random picture you know like
ha taking care of your boy you know um
but yeah it was uh you know yeah we we
learned a lot and I and I I taught
pretty much everybody who's uh an
operating seal now if if you went
through buds in the last 13 years you
probably remember my name cuz coach YOLO
is kind of hard to forget actually 16
years cuz I was worn officer for three
so was 16 years total that I was uh I
was working there and um it was it
wasn't the best job I ever had in my
life but I give it second best you tough
to beat being an assaulter but teaching
people how to do the job man that's
awesome and then and so now now you're
done with that and we kind of already
talked about what you're doing now but
just just so we've got what's the
website that you what's your website
yeah sorry practical practical Firearms
instruction uh.com and on there you know
I do individuals I'll do groups whatever
um you know and it's just a matter of
scheduling these days because I I've
gotten pretty busy you know I mean I've
been back to uh
uh Tennessee and Massachusetts uh
working with the Smith and Wesson guys
trying to get this uh you know the
initial um pistol offering from Lipsy uh
you know uh in fact I'm I'm going there
what day after tomorrow nice for their
the grand opening they're moving a lot
of their manufacturing stuff down to
Tennessee from Massachusetts yeah well
there's a reason for that pay attention
Massachusetts come on
people yeah be be business friendly out
there that's my recommendation and you
you have an Instagram too which is @
practical Firearms instruction yeah I
think so I don't see I did all this
stuff just kind of on the side when I
had a day job and I just kind of I
didn't really look at this stuff um but
you know now you know this is becoming
my day job I'm I'm having to make that
adjustment so yeah you know you got a
lot you got a ton of knowledge you know
um 30 years in nssw and a lot of that
really focused specifically on shooting
so for you to not share that knowledge
seems like it would be uh a a bad thing
to do and for you to be able to take
look there's it's a beautiful time that
you can someone like you can can share
your information with anybody that wants
it I mean that's awesome and and then of
course there's like you said there's
more advanced things you people want to
hire you to come out but if they can't
hire you to come out because they don't
have the money or don't have the time
cool there's the information so yeah or
I mean tactical hive.com or just put in
tactical hiive on YouTube and something
will come up you just got to search
backlog and you know I'll teach you how
to hold a gun how to you know Point
shoot and you know just give you gear
ideas you know and and we've been
thinking about this for a long time so
I've shifted this because you know some
of the stuff I was doing was low viz so
we learn to you know go concealed and
all that and that's that's what people
are going to be doing and what you're
going to learn from me is you know how
to use it but there there's
a um priority of training here okay so
number one for training is being able to
employ the gun clearing your garment and
getting the gun into action and then the
next thing is correcting malfunctions
okay I don't care about changing
magazines because you're going to pull
that thing if you get a click instead of
a bang you got to be able to fix it like
right now get those reps in and then
we'll start talking about other stuff
you know um so employing the gun first
and and or you know and then worrying
about uh uh correcting malfunctions and
then we'll go on to other all the other
ancillary stuff but those are the two
things that's what's going to matter
right in the moment right and when we
talk about gear the gear has to work
okay number one it has to be portable
because you can have something that goes
bang every time but it weighs 10 pounds
guess what you know that that Mark 23
it's an awesome pistol but you are not
carrying that you know on a daily basis
so portability is number one okay reli
ability is number two accuracy is is a
far third because most of the you know
uh statistically most of your encounters
are going to be at close range and
you're going to be Point shooting you're
be focused on that Target and you're
just going to point that gun out there
and start squeezing now if you've done
that with two eyes open and you
understand how to aim with two eyes open
and I can teach you how to do that too
that's not hard um that that'll give you
a good you
know a good starting point good
foundation for sure yeah you're going to
start with that Combat First and if you
want to you know Branch out and do other
stuff fine but so you know portability
first reliability and then worry about
accuracy and you know uh you know
capacity of the gun I mean depends you
know you have different threat levels so
I carry a different gun depending on
what my perceived Threat Level is you
know anyway from a little seven sh shot
uh 22 magnum you know revolver Smith and
Smith and Wesson to you know 38 to you
know little Sub Compact 9 mil to a you
know up to a like a Glock 19 or a
uh oh Sig 320 you know so and that's all
depends on what your Threat Level your
perceived Threat Level is going to be
and then you learn how to deal with each
one of those you addess to the gun a
little bit you know all these little
things that that that that come up but
because I've been thinking about these
things for so long you know it's now you
know and I know how to transfer that
information to other people um I will
give it all to you on on YouTube I want
everybody who whether you have money or
not to be able to understand this stuff
and and if you already have a way that's
working for you I'm not going to say
you're wrong you know cuz if I give you
something that's different from the way
you train then you're going to have to
understand you're going to have to
retrain yeah you're going to have to
invest time unra retrain yeah yeah it
it's it's a thing man muscle memory
muscles don't have memory yeah but there
all your your nerves get melinated every
time you do something and if you do it
the same it's yeah th those those
Pathways you know those neural Pathways
get insulated and you start moving you
know a whole lot faster and smoother and
you don't have to think about it as much
but that comes with reps and it comes
you know so I mean I'll get into that
with with guys uh you know I can talk
about it on YouTube but then you got to
go find it if you want to come find me
then you know we'll go to the range and
I'll I'll I'll fix you it it's a pain in
the ass in California because you know
California is so ungun friendly so I
mean we travel to other states uh I
don't like to travel very much I I kind
of like my my wife and my kids my
grandkid shock
waver that burning sage wave the sage
burning you all that stuff man it's all
good um yeah so that's what I'm doing
now um you know at the moment we'll see
what happens with um with the how well
people respond to the gun stuff and you
know the watch band thing I think it's
going to be a million dooll idea you
know because it's not going to be very
expensive but it's going to be really
cool so Commando bands you're going to
want one you I already want one I'll
give you prototype I'm ready for the
Commando
band right on uh does that get us up to
speed then we good yeah man I think so
that's that's up to today man here we
are you know and then I run into you
getting gas
uh hey dude you're not working for the
Navy anymore you should come on my
podcast like man that now's the right
time to do it I suppose right on Carrie
you got any questions uh no questions I
I just I'm a big fan of what you're
doing removing that barrier for gun
under especially new gun owners uh
getting them up to speed that's awesome
man I want nothing more than a carbine
or carbine pistol now to and and maybe
what you say what was that word is a a
pistol caliber carbine is I think the
PCC so that and the Commando band that's
like my Christmas wish list hell
yeah right on you got any any uh closing
thoughts dude I just want to thank you
for allowing me to come up here I I i'
I've been
you know I'm a big fan you honestly you
know Joo you're doing stuff um that
matters you know you're you're bringing
information to people that uh you know
maybe no one knows about you know you
interview guys you're good interview and
people want to come and and and share
their story and uh I enjoy just
listening I mean obviously it's not
there's no like time limit here cuz you
know you just keep going you know start
you know but awesome this has been
really really good and U I just want to
thank you for that man right on bro well
thanks for coming on man it's awesome to
see you and catch up and get your
experiences get your Lessons Learned and
and like I said man thanks for setting a
great example for me as a young new guy
I definitely needed it and uh you know
thanks for your service to the Navy to
the teams and to the country man
appreciate thanks for making me feel old
man hey that's not
me thanks bro Roger that
and with that Mark coach coach YOLO has
left the
building good to see Coach man still
getting after it still still getting
after it after all these years and
what's what I what I was look obviously
awesome to hear about his experiences
and and just a great dude but I like the
fact that he went look just talking
about the health and wellness part of
his journey at one junct
he's sort of like done you know what I
mean he's like oh I got to this point
this many deployments this much time I
was done broken and now back in the game
all the way back in the game yeah man
and and that that stretching piece I
feel that man cuz like the my whole
upper body you know feels like a
clenched fist sometimes you know and God
I feel that like cracking and stuff you
got to stay on top of that stuff yeah
and and but what I like about it is
it's not too late I don't know where you
are right now I don't know what's
happening what's happening in your world
but you might be feeling like oh it's
too late oh I can't I can't do this
anymore I you know this is this goes
back to a conversation I had with Bert
saurin I was talking about overhead
squats I hurt my arm freaking Dean hurt
my arm Dean liser you bastard hurt my
arm doing a showing a move and I
couldn't overhead squat for for months
like 10 months I could not lock out my
arm like I could do a pull-up but I
couldn't go all the way down so I could
do everything you know after a little
bit of time I could do a pull-up after a
little time I could do you know an
overhead press but I just couldn't lock
it out but an overhead
squat I couldn't do so by the time it
finally healed what I had to do is I I I
was like okay I'm going to do overhead
squats I'm going to try it oh I can lock
it out okay that's feeling good but my
Mobility was so bad that I couldn't do
it with like any weight at all so I said
all right well PVC pipe let's let's go
and I'll do p when when this happened I
was using the frame of the squat rack to
keep my to keep the the PVC pipe over
directly over my head like not and I
just started going all right this week
I'll go you know 50% down next week I'll
go 60% down 80% down finally got the
mobility back then I started adding then
I started doing it with the bar then I
started doing it with you know 25 so
just slowly build it back up and what I
told Bert was there's a moment where you
think oh this movement is now gone this
is something that I'm not able to do
anymore because I could have said that
like oh well hell it's really hard for
me it feels uncomfortable if it hurts
maybe that I I I shouldn't do them
anymore and that's the wrong answer you
need to put your ego in check and say
okay time to rebuild that movement time
to get this movement back do not submit
to time and age don't submit it's a
fight but keep fighting do what you do
got to do to get back and what's
incredible is the human being the human
body will adapt and it will make
progress this been proven over and over
again this is just coaches another guy
that's come out and said I was done
didn't have any mobility in my shoulders
sore all day bro broken here this is
hurt and then he put protocols into
place he started doing the proper
maintenance he started cleaning up the
the food cleaning up the workouts doing
the right things getting the stretching
done and now he's back in the game so
that's what we're doing that's what
we're doing and it's great to hear coach
great dude and thanks to him for coming
on and and by the way one thing you can
do with this deaf reset right this is a
good way to get yourself back on on on
the path the path and you know you and I
were talking about the path yesterday
because we're talk you know you and I a
few other people we were talking about
the what happens in people's
lives what little turns they make what
little decisions they make what little
moves they make and and let's face it
every decision you
make is g to is going to have an impact
and if you take that little decision to
eat a
donut versus the little decision to eat
a piece of beef jerky
and you start multiplying those and
compounding those out they they change
who you are if you make a little
decision that I'm going to sleep in
today versus the little decision that
you know what I'm just going to get up
and push through this workout and you
multiply that over time these are two
different people these are two different
human beings in six months in six months
in six months that transformation can
take place and then what else happens
what else happens what else goes on when
you start making one bad decision you
talking about drinking actually you know
we were on that uh hanging out and you
were talking about you know basically if
you were drinking MH things were going
to go down if you weren't drinking
things were going to get better you're
like hey I might not get in I might not
have a a a chaos night tonight I might
not take some big giant step back
tonight if I have a few drinks but in
the next three times of drinking
something's going to happen and I'm
going in the wrong
direction otherwise you just put that
and be like okay I'm not doing that
anymore which is the decision you made
I'm not doing that anymore and all of a
sudden now my life's not going backwards
my life's going forward every the
trajectory of your life
changes and that's what this is to me
it's so important to think about our
lives and the trajectory of Our Lives
because that's what's the meaning of
trajectory it's where we're going it's
where it's what it is where we're going
is our trajectory going up or is our
trajectory going down and every little
decision that you make either elevates
it or it starts to bring it down so keep
that in mind that's that's de reset
right de reset is an opportunity to say
okay for this for the next 30 days I
know I'm going up my trajectory will be
going up and that is going to put that
trajectory on a on a pace and in a
direction that if you look up in six
months you look up in the ear you're a
different
person that's what we're doing and it
comes down to that PVC pipe decision
right some people are more afraid of
taking that step back of of picking up
that PVC pipe than they are of letting
go of the overhead squat for the rest of
their their lives they'd rather let that
go and never do it again than have to
sub subordinate that ego pick up that
PVC pipe and start from Square One
and that's where that decision gets made
and there are PBC pipes all over life
all over your life where you look at
that thing and you you you subordinate
that ego pick up that PVC pipe start at
square one again that little step and
you start to build and that's where you
start to get the momentum get that
trajectory yeah get back on the path so
de reset it's we're doing it in January
but you got to prep for it now I just we
posted some videos I posted a little
podcast about about it just get start to
prepare for
it uh workouts and fitness Jason kipa is
going to be guiding those things
leadership with ason front I'm going to
give some some discipline directives and
then Joo fuel it we're all doing it
together um the defret decom go check it
out and by the way Joo fuel get yourself
get yourself ready for it get your get
the junk food out of your house get the
freaking Doritos out of your house get
the chocolate chip cookies out of your
house
get mold cookies that's what we're doing
so joof fuel.com get your greens get
your creatine creatine is so good for
you it's good for your mind it's good
for your body get get get these things
so that you're ready you can kick this
thing off right you're going to have
you're going to be working hard during
de reset so get yourself some joint
Warfare some super just you guys know
what we're doing joof fuel.com go get
the fuel that you need you can get also
get it at waa you can get a vitamin shop
GNC military commissaries Apes Hanford
Dash stores in Maryland wake Fern shop
right HB down in tahos Meyer up in the
midwest Harris teer Lifetime Fitness
Shields small gyms all over the place I
know we got Victory MMA and fitness
we're here guess what we sell joof fuel
if you want to sell Joo fuel at your gym
email JF sales joof fuel.com if you if
you're going to a gym and you want them
to joof fuel give them that information
so they can make it happen
so that's what we're starting off with
some joof fuel.com also origin
usa.com
americanmade
clothing Freedom that you put on your
body Liberty that you
wear that's what we're doing at origin
USA anti-slavery
anti-communism
anti-
suffering anti- destruction of the
earth that's what we're doing at origin
usa.com you know what they do with the
the dye and the chemicals that they use
in China when they're when they're done
processing they dump it in the river
goes into the ocean kills everything
they're they're it's
disgusting it's disgusting and all these
big freaking Liars in the fashion
industry with their with their little uh
virtue
signaling talking about how they're for
the environment they're not they're
buying their they're literally paying
for the destruction that's what they're
doing they're Liars they're they're
they're scum so don't help them by
buying their
[__] by
americanmade by origin usa.com that's
what we're doing Jiu-Jitsu gear because
if you're not training Jiu-Jitsu you're
missing out you're missing out 100%
Jiu-Jitsu workout gear hunt
gear t-shirts jeans boots that's what
we're doing we're saving Freedom origin
usa.com we also talked a lot about the
path today and you can get your
discipline equals Freedom gear
representing on the path at Joost store
that's Joost store.com uh t-shirts
rashguards hats just going with the
script you're going with the with the
echo Charles with the script
representing on the P going with the
script got to hold it down for just
holding it hold it down for the Hawaiian
that's what we're doing that's what
we're doing man well if you were going
to say something
that was your own let's say let's say
you had the creative Liberties just to
get crazy what would you be saying about
off fire one off let's see where you're
at here's a test this is a test so there
there's something there's something that
happens to you deep inside when you
throw on anything with the X flag this x
flag that's on my left arm right here as
soon as I put on a shirt that has that X
flag on it something inside of my brain
changes my eyebrows drop a a little bit
my chin lowers my shoulders come back a
little bit I am ready to go into what
I'm about to do when I throw on any
piece of clothing with the X flag on it
I don't know what it is but that's what
happens to me and I see that with other
people too I've been in the we've been
in the airport and we've seen a de core
flag you know a de flag on a shirt in
the wild and that person is ready to get
after it and they come up and they say
what's up and they talk about how
they're on the path and how they're in
the game
and and we go and we do work and that's
what I like to see there's EC got just
just got left in the dust he's been
saying the same [__] for the last five
years and you rolled in I put you on the
spot a little bit but you were ready you
know why you had that def core flag on
you were like what oh you want me to
talk to you want me to say what's up
I'll tell you what's
up it's the truth K dog coming in hot
you will feel it and if you if you want
if you want a de shirt a new DEA shirt
every month we've also got the shirt
Locker that's a subscription service and
Echo Charles just going crazy on the
designs just awesome designs um and a
lot of good reception from the Troopers
in the game too um and every event we're
at now there's there's kind of a a
segmentation of of the the the get after
it just great shirts and then you see
the that shirt Locker shirt and it
stands out and there's a whole group of
people who are in the game on the shirt
shirts and we see them and we say what's
up and we recognize them check check it
out Jo store.com check out Primal
beef.com Colorado
craftbeer life you need you and I had
steak last night matter of fact that was
some good steak but I'll tell you what
you I could tell it wasn't the best
steak it wasn't Colorado craft beef it
wasn't Primal beef it was normal steak
look it's ribey I'm not turning down a
ribeye yeah I mean I'm I'm going to get
into it
I get into it but now that I regularly
eat Primal beef and Colorado craft beef
now that that's just part of the whole
scene you know the the normal ribey they
don't do it anymore yeah yeah they just
don't do it anymore so check those out
also subscribe to the podcast also Jo
underground.com also YouTube channels
check them out we got the the Joo Joo
podcast YouTube channel we got the Joo
fuel YouTube Channel we got the origin
USA YouTube channel we got the aelon
front YouTube
channel we got all kinds of YouTube for
you to watch psychological warfare get
that if you don't have it I guess if you
don't have it by now you probably I mean
your life is probably falling apart you
know so sorry but if you want to get
your life back together psychological
warfare wherever you can get an MP3 it's
in there Flipside canvas.com tood Meer
out there making cool stuff for you to
hang on your wall and keep you on the
path books you know I've written a bunch
of books
get them the new the newest version of
leadership strategy and
tactics mod 2 is out there's some key
information some key updates in there
the the extreme ownership leadership
Loop talk to you about how to make
decisions you and I were in a critical
situation the other day and you know
what the you know what the first thing
in the extreme ownership leadership
loopus what's the number one thing's
time time so you and I were in a Time
critical situation and we reviewed what
had happened my entire thought process
took place in less than one
minute you can tell that if you review
what I did the the very first thing I
thought of was time this is I need to
make a decision right now and that's
exactly what I did all in one minute
right a whole gamechanging scenario was
unfolding and in one minute I had
already made a decision and was
executing right like that's a thing and
we have receipts to confirm that yeah
well that's the thing we went back and I
was like you know we had a we had a
whole scenario that could have blown up
right and then we kind of were
debriefing it and I was like let me pull
out the receipts on this and sure enough
everything was done in one
minute and that that's that's the
benefit of running the loop habitually
yep getting those reps in you get quick
with it yep and it was just all boom
Going Down and the time the immediate
decision was made and then it was like I
was running the rest Loop okay how do we
how do we support what's happening right
how we going to cover Move we we need a
simple plan right here like just went
through it that's what we do yep and
guess what all worked out kind of to a
100% level kind of really worked out 100
so that's what we're doing get that uh
leadership strategy and tactics the new
one the mod two of that field manual and
then I got a bunch of other kids books
the kids books adult books check out the
kids books way of the warrior Kid 1 2 3
4 and five these are going to help the
kids that you know all of them this is
Christmas right here by the way oh yeah
this is what you do for Christmas this
is what you do for every kid that you
know oh what do you do what do you get
what do you get for Christmas for a kid
you change their life you change the
trajectory of their life that's what you
do for Christmas for a kid Warrior kid
box has the flag in it has the book in
it this is what you do for kids there
you go freaking Santa carry over there
putting out word bro my niece and nephew
hell yeah got Warrior kid stuff they are
Warrior Kids in the game now and my
brother-in-law my sister and
brother-in-law's garage hangs the
warrior kid flag they are in the game
now how old are they uh seven five and
seven how they doing awesome focused
focused uh little dude my uh my nephew
has to be benched in games because he
scores too much that that's what's
happening bro yeah that's what I'm
saying little dude you might want to get
your kids these books and your neighbor
kids cuz wouldn't it be nice if there's
a fire at your house someday and your
neighbor who's 9 years old comes over
breaks out a hose and puts out the fire
before it engulfs your your house be
nice wouldn't it that's what a warrior
kid's going to do you know what a normal
kid's going to do for keep playing video
games that's what's going to happen
don't let's get the neighborhood watch
going with the children so there you go
Warrior kids also front we have a
leadership consultancy we solve problems
through
leadership that is what we do we work
with companies we embed into companies
and we help align the leadership around
the principles that we utilized in
combat that we utilize inside of all
these businesses that you hear us talk
about and that we've helped scores of
other companies
get increased
profitability get inre increased
efficiency and get improved
relationships up and down and across
their chain of
command this is what we do at Echelon
front so go to Asom front.com if you
need leadership Consultants inside your
organization we Al also have some Live
Events you can check those out also at
Eon front.com we have a train an online
training platform as well it's at
extreme ownership. comom this is where
you can learn these
principles that you can then apply to
every aspect of your life I don't care
what you're doing right now I don't care
if you're a 22-year-old that's hunting
for a job and you're making uh you know
80 bucks a week working in the school
library you still need a plan you need
to put things together you need to
figure things
out you can utilize these leadership
principles if you're that person or if
you're the CEO of a giant company with
8,000
employees we will teach you these
principles extrem ownership.
comom that's what we're doing comply
them across the board yes sir uh also
extreme ownership academy uh new course
out uh extreme ownership for middle
management a lot of demand for that
one questions all the time about hey I'm
a I'm a new leader or I'm a just got
promoted to a middle management
position what do I do that course is
going to tell you yeah and I guess I
should have made that a little more
clear yeah it doesn't matter if you're
the lowest person on the totem poll that
just got hired or you're out looking for
a job or you're the senior person at
that organization or you're anyone in
between go to extreme ownership. comom
learn the skill of leadership also if
you want to help service members active
and retired you want to help their
families gold star families check out
Markley's mom mama Lee she's got a
charity organiz ation and if you want to
donate or you want to get involved go to
Americas Mighty warriors.org
also we've got Heroes and horses. org
help mink bring our veterans up into the
mountains so they can find themselves
and then Jimmy May's organization beyond
the
brotherhood. org and actually coach has
done some stuff for them as well so
check that out if you want to help
veterans transition to the civilian
sector we appreciate it if you want to
connect with us on the algorithms on on
the websites of the world well let's
remember what we've got for coach
coaches you can check out practical
Firearms instruction.com you can check
out tactical hive.com and also he's on
the the gram at practical Firearms
instruction and of course car is at
Carrie Helton straight up we we got it
handled we did it last time you you sat
in the chair what was going on you had
an underscore in there I I had an
underscore in there Kore hton shout out
to Jack Daniel Hill just getting getting
it done no matter what it I what can you
what else can you throw at that kid like
bro let's face it any if you got the
let's face it Carrie Helton you want to
talk about the trajectory of your life
when you had that underscore in there
bro bro nothing was good nothing was
going good it was just like the whole
world was kind of falling apart then
it's you meet someone now we we have to
talk about you on the podcast we want to
talk about how to connect with you we
just need to say k hton Kon we don't
need to say
underscore back up we're we're on the
trajectory is looking on so check out uh
car hton no
underscore and I'm at Joo willing just
watch out for the algorithm it's going
to grab you and it's going to try and
kill
you am I exaggerating I don't know it's
going to kill your time I promise you
that and what are you you are your time
so yep it's killing you watch out for it
thanks once again to Mark coolo uh for
joining us just awesome to see you
awesome to talk to you and awesome to
share your story and it's it's awesome
for guys like Mark to be out here and
communicate and and share his lessons
and there's a lot of guys like Mark in
the shadows you know they're not going
to be on social media they're not doing
these kind of things but they're out
there they're out there protecting
America and thanks to all those folks
that are out there right now doing this
we don't see them we don't see them on
on social media we don't see them you
know um in the interwebs we don't see
them why because they're out there doing
God's work so thanks to all the folks in
uniform around the world right now In
Harm's Way to keep us free
and the same goes to our police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers border
of Patrol Secret Service all First
Responders thank you all for going into
Harm's Way Every Day to Keep Us Safe
here at
home and everyone else out there as
coach taught countless seals over the
years keep your eyes on that Target
because that's where it's
happening and that's how you get things
done and until next time this is
e and until next time this is not Echo
this is Carrie and Joo
out